a direct relation to uh the offense and
the profession um that they are
practicing in and there's a bit of a
balancing test that's employed um with
the burden being on the licensing board
to demonstrate that somebody's more
likely to reffund with the professional
license so with the current standard uh
it's very difficult to deny a license
based on a criminal conviction alone now
um putting the convictions aside um the
issue from a lenser standpoint is always
going to be whether the conduct itself
um is considered professional misconduct
and um the one the one thing that I
wanted to to note today which which is
it's in R and numeral 10 under 318
F20 it refers to it says this section
does not authorize any person to engage
in and does not prevent the imposition
of any penalties we engaging in the
following conduct undertaking any task
under the influence of cannabis when
doing so would constitute negligence or
professional malpractice it wasn't clear
to me um whether malpractice is is the
best term to use from a legal standpoint
malpractice is a particular type of
civil claim requires Duty breach
causation and damages in a licensing or
disciplinary route we don't consider
damages and we don't consider
causation um so you may want to consider
whether you changed the term
professional malpractice to Prof
professional
misconduct um it will almost always be
professional misconduct to uh perform um
or provide services to a patient if you
are um using certain substances whether
they be prescribed or not prescribed um
if it's inhibiting your ability to do
the job safely it will not necessarily
be professional malpractice if you don't
cause harm to the patient so that's a
distinction that you may want to
consider um but that was the only thing
that popped out when I was Rie that I'd
be happy to answer any questions
Senator questions regarding professional
license chair than that one edit which
does everybody agree with that edit
changing it from Mal practice to
misconduct think that was the word you
said Lindsay yes correct is everybody
okay with that change good any other
questions for Lindsay Lindsay do so some
of our lure the federal lure piece right
I'm a little concerned about things like
electricians and HVAC that have to have
special
licenses and can't that are subject to
potential random drug testing and POS
and and cite coming up up as positive
does that have how does that play into
this and how does that work so I think
I'm not familiar with a particular
license that issue um I know that there
could be concerns with DEA registrations
um obviously the state law you know to
the extent there would have to be like a
preemption analysis involved there so
that's not controlled by by state law so
it could be that um use of cannabis
under state law it's totally permissible
but it's not permissible and if you want
to get your da registration that would
they would have to follow the federal
law um I'm not aware of any other
Federal licenses from our standpoints we
see this a lot in variations of the law
between the states abortion is a primary
example right there are many different
abortion laws throughout the state
what's considered criminal and or not
lawful in other states may be considered
lawful here vice versa um essentially
what we do is we apply the law in New
Hampshire if there's a preemption issue
um then certainly you know the federal
Authority could take a different
position but our perspective in New
Hampshire under the licensing Authority
is that New Hampshire LW
governs anything else right represent K
I mean what about pilot Pilots so we
don't regulate Pilots uh under our
licensing Authority so I can't speak I
can't speak to that
representative so I guess for the
committee convers one uh the state
regulates police
officers would you say that police
officers will be allowed to use
marijuana I would not be able to speak
to that I I don't have uh police
standards and training is not under our
agency that the Mr chair I mean the
chief brings up a great point I mean you
can't have a gun and marijuana at the
same time
so I I would raise the ISS I think the
way you need to the way you might want
to consider looking at the issue is um
is it goes back to my earlier comment is
a professional misconduct for a
professional to be engaging in certain
Behavior while on the job even if it's
legal if I were to be practicing law and
drinking alcohol all day which is
perfectly legal one may argue uh that at
some point I've crossed the line and I
could be subject to discipline by our
regulatory Authority um so certainly
there's all sorts of conduct out there
that's legal but when um but you need to
have U there are ethical constraints as
to what you can
do even if it is you know I mean there's
a lot of issues we're not really talking
about I mean for example you know I've
been I've been injured on the job
multiple times due to negligence of
people using drugs on the job mean I had
an amputation from it so you know what
happens when someone gets hurt at work
because they're high on the job you know
what I mean
like yes so I think that in reading the
legislation and I'm not taking a
position one way or the other just to be
clear um in reading the legislation the
licensing Authority assuming there is a
licensing Authority would have the
ability to take action because the the
issue is is whether that person
committed professional misconduct and
providing Services while impaired which
is something that we routinely take
action on um right now and I don't see I
don't think there's anything in this uh
legislation that would prevent us uh
from doing that if this were to pass as
is and if if the commission believes
otherwise we would want to make clear
that we would still have that
Authority anything else so again I I I
think some of the conversation we're
having and I'm not sure again this might
be a majority Minority Report kind of
thing is again looking around this idea
of non-discrimination for state legal
cannabis activities and prior
convictions right so we we have this
convers under under here it says
acceptance provided in the section a
hold of a professional occupational
license may not be subject professional
discipline for and B is engaging in
lawful activities of the state which is
marijuana consumption right so I guess
the question is around law enforcement
is one right we have a state
certification for law enforcement and if
you're if if you pop positive through
because you're going to be subject to
random drug testing you can be generally
when you're involved in a in a critical
incident um you'll be drug tested and if
you pop positive does this prohibit law
enforcement from disciplining an officer
who may end up testing positive for th
presence it prohibits a police officer
even applying to be a police officer one
year prior okay so if they're using a
year prior to applying they're
ineligible to be a police officer so I
think that needs to be question how do
we deal with this non-discrimination
language when we have job functions in
the state um that necessarily would
would prohibit would would would
discriminate against testing if you test
positive you can't get a
license and yet this section would
absolutely prohibit that I mean don't
you think we should discriminate against
school bus drivers getting high not
argue who we should or should not
discriminate against all I'm saying is
that I think we have some discussion
that's to happen here or resolution or
whether we even take it up whether we
leave this language in there at all and
just leave it to um instead of having a
state law that says you can't
discriminate against when we have
problems we leave that as an open item
um either for the um policy board to
take up or for future legislation um not
include it in in the legalization
component one thing to consider Senator
if May is whether um the way we view
things in the office is there's a
distinction between employment decisions
and Licensing decisions licensing is
intended to ensure that you're minimally
competent that you have the basic skills
doesn't mean that I want to hire you um
and so the question that you may want to
consider is um from a liur standpoint uh
do you find that the nondiscriminator
non-discriminatory Clause should apply
to lure but allow employers to dictate
the terms of their employment that is
something that you can
consider I I think this talks
specifically about professional
occupational licensed positions right so
not necessarily a parking attendant
right but again police officer nurse
teacher school bus driver uh commercial
driver right these are all licensed
professional or occupational
licensees that I can see would want
restrictions on um that what when I
worked for the an Electric Co-op I had
to get drug tested right so was it was a
condition to my employment would I would
they be allowed to turn me down if I
tested positive at TH presence um
working in in as an employer based on
this I'm not sure they would um be able
to uh turn me down for or subject me to
discipline so that's my concern is
businesses that have implemented
standards we're now going to prohibit
those standards by passing the section
my my reading I mean I I agree agree
with you and and you know we could
potentially be increaseing cost to
businesses because their insurance costs
are going to go up if they're not
allowed to just to have a drug-free
workplace you know we're going to be
hurting small
business I also have a concern that
we're really just setting businesses up
for lawsuits just non-discriminatory
lawsuits all the time well I I guess I
should have asked I know that I once I
used the word uh discrimination in a
bill and I got taken a task because we
have a whole Commission that talks about
discrimination and what discrimination
is and how it's applied and and I had to
change my bill because it had to deal
with the uh with with that one word and
because we have a commission that deals
with all the complaints around that um
you would had to create a special class
of people and the whole nine yards and
it was kind of ugly so um so that causes
me some concern we talk about
discrimination um so anyway thank you
Lindsay I think everyone's good thank
you appreciate sh your
time all right so I forgot to go over
the minutes uh so we're going to back up
a minute and I'd entertain a motion to
adopt the minutes as written and
presented
anybody it's been moved by Senator delis
sander second by um director mik is
there any changes or amendments to the
minutes of um
11:16 see none all those in favor say I
all oppose nay
I have it the minutes are adopted all
right so I we're in a hurry up and hold
mode I think daily daily can you check
with Ryan see where we are with red
lines because we can't we can't really
go very far unless we have a red line
copy all right so why don't we do this
we'll take a a five minute break
hopefully we'll get those Redline copies
back um and we'll be able to move
forward with going through the red line
copies and make sure we cover all the
changes everyone's Mak you'll have in
front of you there's some language you
probably want to take read while we're
waiting you should have in your email
this morning you should have got some
recommended languages from Nami um on
what they want to see with that word
recovery and mental health um you have
uh on your desk you should have a copy
of some language around an nment that
was prevented by presented by Frank at
the ACLU um to take a look at as
well and we'll take those changes up
also in the red light won't be in the
redline copy we'll be adding adding
those in addition to the redline
copy
great thank you guys five minute break
we'll be back at um
9:25 actually let's just say 9:30 let's
take a 10
minute
right through it with my head down so I
may not necessarily see you raise your
hand so on the first page we struck uh
uh right at the top that whole uh number
one in
findings um on the
um down on number F on that first page
we changed uh will to shall we missed um
a change that I had I had written in so
it'll have to be added and it was that
marketing ad advertising the miners will
be prohibited as number G as letter G
should have been in there and it's not
there so we'll add that to the new bill
um so again on the first page we have
the a through F we had put in number G
we had added number G that just or
letter G G that said U marketing and
advertising the minor prohibited yeah I
had that note yep I had that note also
and then I had on F that we we struck
tax from CH fee no we just said Revenue
rather than tax just that okay turning
the page to page
two uh most of this involved um the
adding the word treatment in the funds
yeah
doctor we had discussed last time also
saying uh substance use disorder as
opposed to substance abuse to be in uh
conjunction with the current language so
on page two what line number so it's on
it's essentially in probably 30 places
throughout the document but anytime it
says substance abuse to put substance
use disorder you should do a a search
for the whole document and replace it
search and replace okay
yep so if I'm looking at this just right
at the top right we talk about uh uh
line 12 right so substance and you want
used to uh prevention or substance so
and so there's on line two on line five
on line seven um oh so it on line 14 on
12 14 it's in a lot of lot of I'm sorry
doctor just to be clear that it should
go from substance abuse to substance use
disorder so any place that says
substance abuse or substance misuse we
could put substance use disorder and
that would that would cover any of those
so for the entirety of the document
corre
um the other thing on on um you should
have gotten in your email this morning
um Nami finally sent us the language for
um the allocation component what they
were what they're asking well hold on
actually we have that in a different
section the allocation so we'll address
it in another section
um no actually that's not true one
second let me pull it
out
easier uh that's
the you have it oh guys see
it no
that's so Nami wanted
on uh is that the right
section 26a
number looks like give me one second
guys trying to find it on the
page
so under number five on page two um
letter
B um the L right now you know you can
read what it has but Nami would like to
change that to is voluntary and
involuntary programs for mental health
treatment with or without substance use
disorder
diagnosis so one more time it says
voluntary and involuntary programs for
mental health treatment with or without
a substance abuse
Disorder so basically would allow
funding to go to those that program is
that reasonable to everybody so we'll
add that in we'll we'll strike that and
replace um B with
that
Y Line
34 page
two line starting at line
okay so that's added in
um it's a different section of B uh
anybody have any other changes online on
page
two see I had
a coming back
to
three this was the issue about having a
right so Dave that was assignment I
think that was given to you about
changing language to say that the fund
would be spersed based on your
commission not on DHHS for
the you're good with it okay
great uh page three we struck section
five
yep we added the word cultivating on
line
22 uh let me just harvesting and
cultivating cultivating and harvesting
yep it's in there sorry perfect they're
both in there
yep
um okay anything else on three well
let's just just pause on the definition
of
cannabis and remember the conversation
about
CBD I think that's covered though right
yep we wanted to make shall not include
hemp exctly right hemp by projects which
deals with the F Bill
okay going on to page
four um we struck section six for um
cannabis accessory
retailer um we didn't break out like I
asked for a and d but that's fine
um I had on line eight I had a a flag
that instead of registered oh yeah I had
a liced yeah they added what they ended
up doing was just adding registered and
license so
me
um eight Dr I think you did you give us
a new definition for number eight the
Cannabis products definition looks like
we struck the term sh not apply to
cannabis in its plant or flower form I'm
not sure why we struck that
but was that was that definition
okay
okay we we because because in the bill
we have cannabis retail store um
franchise and franchise cannabis retail
outlet defined in two different places
we just changed the Cannabis r retail
store rather than changing the bill in
every location was found just saying
that it refers to the def the other
definition if you see this it means that
could
I just before we get too far can we just
go back
to um five on page two R numer five I
just want to make sure uh is this saying
that my reading of this allocation shall
be used for one of the more of the
following so that does that
limit any any of the other funding or
anything else except what's listed
there so that is a limiting factor so
that would be mean that these fourth
items are the are what can be used for
so again it could be used for but are we
talking about all the money that's
coming in from revenues because if that
only the revenue that's allocated to the
fund
right so not not 100% of all the of the
money coming in but the money that's
allocated for the purposes of treatment
the 10% or 25 million I think was the
language that money could only be used
for these four subject items okay yeah
sorry to sorry back to where we
were
um nothing else on four going over to
five um we had a bunch of uh um
strikeouts and and number 17 18 19 all
were
struck
um I did have one note here and it was a
I don't want to start a a war but the
question was around um I made a note
that online ordering but in store pickup
I had the same note no delivery but can
do inore in person pickup we want to be
able to allow them to be able to order
online but you have to go in the store
show your ID to pick up the order uh
it's just reasonable retail Market
marketing so is there a discussion
around that are we okay with that we add
that language in under the franchise
retail anab
it I have a question sure if you allow
this will you will allow someone from
Massachusetts to order online or we'll
pick a state that's not legal order
online here in New Hampshire and come to
New Hampshire and pick that up and take
it back home so the reality is the
answer is yes to that um but again we
would they can do that now they can
drive here and walk in the store and buy
it the only difference is we're on a on
a functional operational level we
allowing the store to be able to have
basically a pickup line that you've
already placed your order and just go
pick it up for streamline purposes
rather than walk in and have to go
select your
product but that same person would be
able to walk into any retail store and
buy in the Hampshire if you're from I
understand that I think that with the
online it would
facilitate the illegal Market in another
state and we're making it easier to do
that okay you're welcome to give a call
out note on the uh in the in the report
that you're concerned about that um for
the policy committee to take that topic
up Chief Mr I was going to say just much
like liquor if somebody orders from out
of state we don't penalize them or don't
allow them to do that they're not
breaking the law in the state of New
Hampshire
and they would not be breaking if this
passed they would not be breaking the
law in the state of New Hampshire to
purchase it here so that that's the
premise behind the idea of people doing
it from out of state they have a second
home here they order product I
understand that but I I my concern is
that another state that it's not legal
in and they're ordering from
there well if we I mean put the caveat
on it that it's not legal in another
state but they have a home here in New
Hampshire or they're coming here to New
Hampshire to visit they've rented a home
for a month they order it online they
pick it up and they're here but it's not
legal in the state that they're in
there's so many different C just
throwing that out because there's so
many different caveats to allow that
being
done so sen so we'll add it in that
online ordering but in store pickup is
allowed so it's so it's no question
about that um and then anybody wants to
add a comment line into the addendum
report for the bill um sen of whle
brought up under
16 um the last line that's currently
printed on there it says alternative
treatment centers cannot be licensed to
duly operate from the same location as a
franchise cannabis retail outlet I think
we struck that and it should be struck
because we've decided we're going to
allow dual use stores however if a if if
we're going to do medicinal and a and
ATC choose to move into the retail
Market they'll be governed 100% by The
Liquor Commission no longer by DH H HS
if they want to stay in ATC they can and
just do therapeutic they can be
regulated over by DHHS is that where
everybody is
at okay so we're going to strike that
line that last sentence that says
alternative treatment centers cannot be
licensed to duly operate the same
location as a franchise retail outet
we're striking that
line um the next argument Point's going
to be number 21 we're talking about
possession limits um so this uses the
big change in here is in
um 5 gram of concentrated product um and
from down from 20 and then uh uh C is a
new line that I don't remember having a
conversation about but I'll leave it for
discussion cannabis products other than
concentrated Canabis products contain no
more than 80% concentration of THC M Mr
chair what's it so so let let's take
let's do them in order so let's start is
everybody okay with um a the under
possession limit
4 ounce possession we agreed to bring
that down to two ounces I do believe the
two was the conversation what I had in
my notes um but I think the con the
problem with two in a retail environment
is someone who goes buys their weeks
worth of product and brings it home
would be violating if you had personal
consumption which is what we had before
you could have two ounces but and so I
think that's where the language is that
the fact that we're entering into a
retail Market we have a higher minimum
position possession limit but and
anything above that is possession with
intent right so just remember anything
above the 4 oun is possession with
intent to sell um or at least that would
be the argument made by law enforcement
um is that it would be possession with
intent to sell your legal limit for
personal use is 4 ounces anything above
that it's not personal use
anymore so we're getting rid of all
guidelines on this not all guidelines
we're we're still setting a limit that
allows law enforcement to do their piece
um I the five grams versus 20 grams um
um and then the last one and this one
I'll need some help from the committee
because again I don't remember a
conversation around this um cannabis
products containing no more than 80% of
concentration of THC I had that we were
doing 2,000 down to
500 that's what I had for a note but
that's why I'm asking the committee if
anybody knows where this language came
from any any of the ATC guys know the
the language came from the gentleman in
the back
so cannabis product so again we're
talking about what a possession limit is
cannabis products other than
concentrated
cannabis products containing no more
than 80% of concentration of THC does
anybody know where that language came
from well we we struck out the 2,000
milligrams because he told he well we
had I I had in here that we were
changing the change was that we were
going from 80% con that I don't know
where the 80% came in we were just going
to change 2,000 milligrams to 500
milligrams that's what I had too that's
what I have in my notes and I'm looking
to see where direction we should
head what's
it right so so how about we go back to
the original language except for 2,000
we'll say 500 I mean I don't think we
should put any guidelines I think we
should just you know
damn I just on that note I do think that
this is an area I'm sure that members
will want to provide additional comment
in the final report policy committee is
going to yeah any comment you want to
add you can for the report on those
possession limits and also again
remember the Pol this isn't the end
right this is just we're getting to the
beginning um of the bill which is it'll
go in front of the policy committee
whether in the senate or house for
further discussion on on possession
legis yeah it's going to be it's yeah um
and I and just a note on that I do think
it is important to make those comments
should you have them and I because that
I think will signal to to the policy
committee it right it will signal to the
committee discuss yeah where the
critical discussion points are so I do
think it's important to do that again it
this be a call out saying on possession
limits the committee was still have you
know needs this view
fa
well so I think again under under
B I think is where they're talking about
five grams for the purposes of
vaping I think the
um right under under go back under
possession limit
B and I think the second one was
relative you're right I think it was
relative to Edibles and the idea being
that I think somewhere along here we
talk about any single serving having
five milligram is that
right and so the idea being if you were
buying a package of 20 you'd have 100
potentially 100 milligrams in your
possession even though each serving is
only five milligrams right and so this
was to allow for a package of more than
one product I think that's what we're
talking
about it says other than concentrated
product cannabis products other than can
concentrated
products so again I think this goes back
to your gummy right one gummy may have 5
milligram of THC and you can hold a
package of 20 which would have 100
milligrams of THC and you're not be in
violation of the of the
uh right so going 500 then
500 should be I I don't know how many I
don't
know so you want to go to 100 I have no
I I'm I'm open here I this language was
changed from what I had so in discussion
100 milligrams is
what's a typical concentrate
C okay that's right multiple right
that's that's the issue is it so are you
saying that in any single container you
can only have 100 John and yet but you
can have up to five containers this
sentence is not
clear that sentence implies to
one well it's just a total possession
limit so we'll leave it at 500 then if
we think we need to again we can do a
call out note in the bill that just says
that in any whether a single package
contain no more than 100 and you're
allowed up to 500 in
total
yep
um
okay
um the next thing I had is I had us that
we struck the whole resident definition
because we already found a chapter of
law that Frank brought forward that
defines residents so that should be
struck again from the bill I had that
too be okay with
that
um then we get into the personal use
section
um
uh I had on line so we're on page
six
line uh
17 I think we said staff are of a
licensed cannabis product man I had that
as
well so right before the word cannabis
on line 17 we're just going to add the
word
licensed make it
clear we struck section two which was
the sanctuary City
language moving on to the next page this
is where we have our oh I'm sorry I'm
sorry going back to page six
yep some reason I had a cross out on
controlling and then to ask represent
hunt I had John's name next to each
other these two Provisions well they
well they both came from 639 um d and e
came from on page six came from six
House Bill
639 I'm gonna leave them as they are
commission help me got it so we'll leave
it and we'll we'll we'll go on um so top
of page seven we have the um we have the
language again I'm going to ask that we
change that language to indicate our
will that there's a primary and a
secondary offense or a first offense and
a second offense and a second offense
should be enhanced penalties I'll leave
a note in I I'm going to put it as just
a misdemeanor a violation of the
misdemeanor and then we leave a note to
talk about um beyond that for I know the
Law Enforcement wants a Min minimum
penalty that's significant um and that
can be in the in the addendum
note so I think that's fine about the
note I mean I think think
we this was an area of obviously a lot
of conversation and so I think the only
consensus that was reached was some sort
of graduated approach so maybe we could
refer to it that way so I think we we
heard from the AG's office that again if
you just put the word vist meter the
first assumption is assumed it's a b
which is no jail time potential but and
and not necessarily and then but allows
for a potential filing of paperwork to
allow for an a if someone's in their
fifth offense on the State House steps
and we could deal with it a little more
severely I'm wondering if uh for
purposes of just transferring this to
the legislature that we put in what the
existing laws with regard to marijuana
possession the the decriminalization I
mean with the three quarters of announc
or less which is the graduated offense
at Fourth offense triggers of be
misdemeanor and so we have precedent for
that New Hampshire law if we just put
that in as place like to leave it to the
policy committee right and so again
that's I think it's an area we're not
going to find a consensus in here to put
down um you know Law Enforcement wants
and heavier minimum standard minimum
fines um I think we just put that it's a
violation of the mistim metor and let
the policy committee decide whether they
want minimum fines or anything else I
don't think we're going to get there so
yeah we're not talking about possession
we're talking about use we're talking
about but he's talking about possession
he's bringing up numbers of ounces we're
talking about use we don't want public
smoking right this is this is right this
is public consumption we're talking
about so first offense violation second
offense of misdemeanor and then we'll
leave it to the policy Comm to find it
any further but I don't think that we I
guess my point is that we didn't reach
consensus about violations and
misdemeanor to be clear like we the
conversation started on reducing 500 to
100 to be consistent with the existing
smoking policy I don't think we reached
consensus on misdemeanor or violation
then misdemeanor I I just don't think we
did so let's do it this way just do a
show a hands because again I think who's
in favor of having enhanced penalties on
a second
offense
the first well again I'm just talking
about the second offense that's really
we I think we all agree it's violation
on the first offense say enhanced
penalties on the second offense enhanced
penalties and they decide what the level
of that penalty would be right right
they can any aggravated meting
circumstances can command that why it
might be a b and why it might be an a
that's up to law enforcement and in the
enforcement action to take yeah I guess
I just to clarify I am fine with an
enhanced penalty on the second offense
but I'm not okay with it automatically
being a misdemeanor I guess that's my
point so so you have apparently your
homework to write a note for the
addendum I already put it in my
note so um so we'll just rewrite that
again just saying that the first offense
violation second offense of misdemeanor
with an a call out just saying we
couldn't come to an agreement on
penalties um why I don't see why would
we put a misdemeanor in there if we put
that language if we're not in agreement
that why don't we put that we there's an
agreement that should be a graduated
penalty and leave it for the policy
people to going from violation to a b is
a violation going from a violation to a
b is an enhanced penalty otherwise you
just have violation of violation with
more fine which we're already giving the
judge a latitude on fine but I think the
point and it doesn't mean a officer
could ple it down too sorry interrupt no
no no I I I agree I agree I think the
point was like you could have we had
actually talked about that graduated you
know going from 100 to 500 that was
where we agreed on and and so I agree
that the note in there should be that
the the committee did not reach
consensus on what what the penalty
should be but we did agree on a
graduated it in you got to put it in you
can't say we agree on it we got you got
to say what the second second use is and
that's why I want to leave it to the
policy committee right let's let the
criminal justice policy committee either
in the house or the Judiciary here in
the Senate deal with what that looks
like I think that we all agree again
that if I just put the first defense is
a violation and we don't allow for the
potential upcharging to a misdemeanor
for any reason then that's not I think
the will was clear we want an upcharging
of that VI of that second offense I
don't know what that looks like I want
to leave it as leave it to the uh policy
committee no and I guess what what I'm
saying and what he's saying is that we
did not agree that we did not agree
about that would be the graduated set of
penalties right we did not agree that it
would go from violation to misdemeanor
on the second offense we didn't agree on
that age I I this way we're not going to
find consensus here but I think we need
to give the policy committee a direction
that says that first offense and second
offense are different I just have a kind
maybe a naive question but if the
purpose of this committee is to provide
recommendation on the feasibility of
legislation right then why are we going
line by line on legislation and not just
writing up a report about some of these
some of these barriers and boundaries on
these main topics because because it
seems like we're when it gets down to
brass tax the the reigning thought is
well we'll just punt that to the you
know for other people to to do but I
mean we're we're half doing it half not
so again the idea being is we're trying
the bill is supposed to be a set of
guidelines that put the most clean
Provisions in but again we're not going
to get to a 100% agreement on some of
this we have some people are going to be
a no no matter what we say in this room
right so we're not going to get to 100%
consump uh uh consensus so in places
where we can agree we want to highlight
that and give that the legisl in place
we can't we want to make sure we do a
call out after the after we have a
defined Bill we we call out these areas
still need further
compensation so banging through the
bill so we're on line seven uh we're
moving on to consumption while
operating um and the big the the we are
okay with one and two um on line three
we change it to a misdemeanor and a fine
not to exceed
$1,000
there's any other changes there this is
my own this is the um we have a couple
changes already to
us um moving on to any uh we struck uh I
have that we struck number five you guys
have that on your
notes I have it crossed out a strike
I thought we were going to strike it
only if we couldn't find that it was
clearly already um
protected but I don't know whose
homework assignment that was I just
haven't I have't crossed out that in the
conversation we chose to strike that
language in because we couldn't come
to you know and that's virtually cut and
pasted from existing precent so we don't
need to codify us not codifying that
doesn't change the law if anything we
might change make confusion so there
don't need to do that we'll strike
five well I just want to take a pause on
that because I
actually I'm not sure I was even part of
that
conversation what can you just Express
what the concerns were with five again
so 265a is the DUI
Statute in that underneath there so
um I again if a police officer pulls
over someone who's smoking
marijuana it pulls up and the car is hot
booxed and they're driving down the road
and they have weaving and they pop them
for DUI they should also be able to pop
for consumption if they have evidence of
consumption in a in a motor vehicle so
my concern with eliminating this alog
together is that one of the reasons why
I am very supportive of legalization is
because of the sort of
disproportionate you know use of um
stops for people of color and using you
know cannabis as one of those I wouldn't
say pretext but the reason and so I
think this is a a very important part
that um is you know part of the overall
conversation for many folks about uh why
legalization is really
necessary so what I'll tell you is this
you get pulled over anyone doesn't
matter what your race is your religion
and it smells like marijuana in the
vehicle it's it's there's no reason to
believe crime has occurred just descent
alone that's what the Supreme Court
ruled so it doesn't matter ending be
putting that in here any further you
don't have to you don't have to actually
put it in the bill right and that's that
adding that in there it's unnecessary
language so it's this we're not saying
that we're not getting into whether it's
a disproportionate impact or not this
applies to everyone every single person
they get stopped the scent of marijuana
alone is not probably cost the search
because there's no reason to believe a
crime has occurred because if it's
decriminalized and that's why the the uh
Supreme Court and New Hampshire already
made that so well again so let let's
back up because again we're to be clear
we're talking about consumption of
marijuana in a motor vehicle um is
prohibited and um while operating and so
the question is can you charge somebody
with consumption of marijuana and
impaired driving at the same time if we
leave this in you would not be able to
if we'd strike it out then you'd be able
to charge him with both consumption of a
mo in um while operating a motor vehicle
as well as operating a vehicle while
impaired I think that's a reasonable law
I think that's a reasonable
interpretation we want to prohibit and
make sure people are not consuming uh
marijuana while driving a vehicle um and
so if the officer has evidence of both
and can prove Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
both we should be allow the charge for
both but if we put this in we wouldn't
be able to you had to pick one or the
other Chief and then Tim if you include
an open container
right provision you should be able to
charge under that in addition to
operating Under the Influence so I think
that's important to have in here that no
open containers
period open containers I'm not sure how
you proove open container from marijuana
but um but again I think I think the
consumption component is important that
if you improve consumption so we're
going to go to Tim Frank did you have
something no and then and Senor Whitley
I was just gonna bring up you know an
open container you know you can get
charged for an open container and oui at
the same time so you know I think you're
right we should strike this
and real simple all those in favor of
striking I had a comment go ahead back
thank you um so I just wanted to respond
to what Senator abbis said about you
know there's a Supreme Court case that
already addresses this and that may be I
I I haven't seen that case so I can't
speak to that but we are the legislature
and you know as we know president some
times you know can change and I think if
it's a policy issue that the legislature
needs to address I don't want to rely on
the Supreme Court case I think it should
be in the statute so I guess this is an
area where many of us will have to
provide a comment right so again you can
add an addendum note and send it to uh
Senator abis and you can add it as an
addendum as a policy area we disagree
with it you disagree with striking it
but all those in favor of striking
number five raise your
hand so the majority of the committee is
in favor so we'll strike number five
moving on on to number um line 27 we
struck this whole
section um moving on to the bottom of
page seven we're okay there moving on to
page
eight
um we added at the bottom of ran numeral
2 we added New Hampshire State Police to
make sure they're included included in
that the rest of page eight is the
same
on the top of the next page on P does
anybody have any comments on page
eight none page nine and just to be
clear um Senator Lang and I didn't
unable to compare our notes over the uh
long weekend shall we say so if there's
anything missing that should be in it's
not in there I do have the word document
pulled up I can add add that to
it just going to say the b botom of Nine
the 24 months yep yeah yeah well there's
still something at the top so again I
had a note on mine on my drafts on top
when we talked about the commission
shall not apply penalties such as
license suspension for an indefinite
period of time and I had the word
revocation written down and I'm not sure
why um we and we remember what that
conversation were were we changing
suspensions to revocations
or if not I'll leave it as it is
remember why I wrote that note seven and
eight were okay okay no changes so this
is where we get into the timeline uh
everywhere it said 24 months we're
changing it to 30 months throughout the
entire
Bill thank you 24 to 30 24 to
30 again nothing
prohibits liquor from coming in sooner
um it just gives them a top a a deadline
that they have to meet so I have no
changes on page
yes or vice chair it looks like we did
strike special seasonal franchise
cannabis retail outlet so that is a
change line 36 uh Daryl where are we
right here this this you struck this but
we didn't in our notes we didn't strike
it so John understand why 16 is
struck thank you
Tim represent
K uh let darl answer then we'll go to
you Doctor how exactly would you do a
special seasonal franchise oh and I I
would prer
to from The Liquor Commission can
explain that it didn't seem like you'd
have a seasonal
St yeah the only way something like that
could happen is if someone wanted to
open a seasonal store in the beach area
or up North during ski season that's the
only we we've we've looked at it over
the years with liquor to open seasonal
stores in different areas I think that's
originally why the language was put in
there but it's it's
unnecessary so the question is do we
need to strike it or should we leave it
just on the off chance as a reason why
we you want to open a season if we
strike it I'm not sure necessarily you
can um but
this I think it should be stricken it
should be strucken
okay page
11 Senator oh I'm sorry dror
um so on um page 10 line 43 um about the
training I certainly we would advocate
for some pretty robust training and my
understanding um is that currently like
you're a bartender in the state you have
to do some annual training but having
something that says you know not
recommended like mandatory training and
continuing education required for lenses
and all franchise uh retail outlet
employees at least annually um and then
maybe something which shall include but
not limited to training because
obviously just being able to check an ID
and for false ID is probably inadequate
um so say like that's like the bare
minimum but really we would want some
more robust training about you know
potency and um High SL low that sort of
thing so how doctor how do you feel if
we add right at the the first word we
just say annual mandatory training
continue education required are
recommended for lenses and all franchise
Canabis retail outlet employees which
shall include but not limited
to that work can we get rid of
recommended because like for liquor it's
not recommend is everybody okay with
Shri recom making a mandatory training
requirement annual training requirement
for all
licenses I don't see any NOS to that so
we'll strike the word or
recommended annual here put um instead
of anual right angle in front remove
recommendations and then put shall
include but not limited
to and I'll give you all my notes for
the CH let's
do
that all right uh page 11 we struck uh
E I had this actually as just an area to
come back to with some homework and I
have something about adding a procedure
for
franchise as well
adding a procedure for franchisees as
well I have it as struck so I don't I
don't have comment on this because the
only thing I wrote was strike
it is there anyone that wishes to keep
keep the language
in so moving on we'll leave it
struck
um the other note I had was on G yeah um
I had we were adding the word and dis
qualifications and disqualifications so
what what would disqualify somebody as
well as what qualifies somebody so I
have a note here that the ACLU was
working on language for that so I think
it was added in here G um I think we
were trying to just clarify that people
with past criminal convictions for
possession would not be discriminated
against so it looks like it was
incorporated here
great so we okay with adding or
disqualifications to that as well as the
language Frank has specifically about
previous convictions Chief G um wanted
to make sure that people that were
convicted of
distribution um wanted to make that we
you know that's why we emphasize by
expressly saying possession Yeah by
saying possession you know possession
with intent distribution illegal
harvesting illegal trafficking all that
would that's that could still be re the
the banit or disqualify it possession
alone would and that's Prett I mean
that's consistent with alcohol if you
have a you know with minor in possession
of of alcohol can still be a bartender
or work work around liquor
so so we'll add the qual We'll add
qualifications or disqualification for
license that are directly
demonstrable um and and include the
language from theu on I we added um
distribution tracking do we was it
supposed to be warehouse and
distribution so that's in a j so if we
can any recommended language if you have
it Now's the Time because I can
literally put it in now and I'm you know
not g to stay at the midnight before you
got here Senator Lang and I were both
taking notes on our on this documents
I'll give I'll give changes but I can
type it as we go yep that's fine do be
less
work
um right so under I we added the word
distribution and then under J we added
warehousing and distribution transport a
warehouse or dist distributed
distributed so those are
ads um anything else on 11th going to
12 we struck um section three all
together it looks like
I think this again
goes the idea that we're you'll either
be an ATC or a retail Center you won't
be both but if you're an ATC that
chooses to move to a for-profit retail
Center um you'll be managed by liquor if
you stay in ATC you'll be managed by
DHHS
and again because we struck three we
struck all of the sub subp parts of
three to go with it on line
30 with line 37 of page 13 does that
need to be 24 months or 30 30 everywhere
it says 24 months it should be 30
months can we go back to page 11 for a
second yep give me one second let just
finish where Daryl is so on line 40 um
we the rule the rulle shall include but
not limited to the
following sorry go back to P which page
I'm sorry Chief page
11 and I'm looking at paragraph L
section
L do we want to denote in here that it
should be an opin for local communities
versus I think that's later on in the
bill
okay I just want to later on the bill we
have what what communities are allowed
and not allowed to
do the 13 other than uh but but not
limited to on the regulatory
stuff Ru making okay going on the next
page
um Senator Lang on um C on line 14 on
page 14 I think think in terms of uh
potency limits I know Kate from new
Futures handed out an updated document
around potency limits I didn't know if
it'd be worth having Kate come up real
quick if we want to quickly talk through
that sorry s where are we talking right
got to talk a little louder in your
microphone you're sorry ask um on line
uh 11c in terms of I'm sorry looking at
the wrong version uh line 14 C around
the potency limits page 14 on page 14
yes
y
so and and who and new future submitted
Kate Kate we want to come up and just
quick talk about uh again the 20
milligram versus
uh is that this is that
this Kate is that this document that you
gave
us it is um my name is Kate fry um vice
president of advocacy at new Futures
I'll be speaking into that document but
but I but thought I should o point out
none of the suggested changes that we
had indicated before had made it to this
draft I don't know if it's something
that maybe is later on but um on page 14
I just wanted to point out that the
committee did decide that 20 milligrams
for um serving size should be changed to
five I had that in my notes as
well so again now we're going back to
the conversation of
product serving a single serving and how
much cannabis milligrams of THC a
product's allowed to have I think five
was the number edible yeah five was the
number and the thought was if you can't
go from 10 to five that would be
problematic if if ever want that is Ever
Raised you know to 10 you know we'll
deal with that then but we can't I it's
too hard to go backwards and I think so
so are we so the com was a five
milligrams per serving basically we we
we totally talked about this a ton and
we agreed on five yeah correct so we'll
change out the
five just make sure we we're talking
about the same thing the way it says
included in each cannabis product is my
memory this is only Edibles this is only
doesn't say Edibles to me it looks like
you're you're going to say even a uh a
joint when someone buys it pre-rolled
there's no way we're Limited
that we don't know how much is in there
this is if you if you go back to where
the whole conversation around the
five was it's about you which back
in back in uh page
five you have 4 ounces of cannabis in
plant
form five grams of concentrated canvas
products would includes as the con so
the key word is
concentrated so that that this here when
you put in that uh that new your new
definition you want to say the con it's
the concentrated
cannabis not Canabis concentrated can
but the definition of cannabis product
uh this term shall not include cannabis
in its plant or flower form so it's a
joint example wouldn't be applicable
because did that was in the beginning of
this paragraph that is in a definition
section on looking at this here and if
you drop that to five I'm concerned you
created some confusion in the statute
well I think I think under the product
definition we exclude plant so it would
not this would provision wouldn't apply
I think five milligrams I'm not com to
with the last sentence though except
there may be changed through rule making
I think that's a legislative function
and I think we should strike that and
let the legislature make a decision on
if this goes to 10 down the
road we shouldn't abgate our rule our
our authority to
legislate we could we finish up with uh
let's finish up with with section c
first then we'll move on to the next one
right so is everybody okay we're going
to change the 20 milligrams to 5
milligrams and strike that last after
the comma but a period after milligrams
that's exactly what I had in my notes
anyway yes okay Doctor back to you um so
just going back slightly to U line for
for the um prohibitions on um things
that make the product more appealing to
Children maybe spec helpful to have a
little bit more expansion in the
diagnosis or in the definition um you
know saying things like bright colors
characters toys things uh to avoid
somebody saying well I didn't mean to
Market this to children but they found
it attractive um just a little more
specificity to hold people accountable
for making things that aren't account or
aren't appealing to
children but the children are not even
allowed in the stores right but if you
have like you know I go to the store and
get something that's you know shaped
like Minnie Mouse and I bring it home my
kids's more likely to think it's candy
or find it appealing to eat than if it's
clear and round um so I just think you
know just saying something that's you
know like you know excluding things that
are brightly colored you know shaped
like characters or toys or you know
commercially marketed candy um I think
we have that in here later on we talk
about the control that liquor has
on pack the get get Mr mol upset but we
just saw this in our beer labeling right
conversation right and so all over again
we already have some controls and
conditions relative to marketing the
children in the in the ru making and
later on in this bill as well it's
spelled out on page 15 and 16 pretty
well we were looking for that it looks
like anything in the candy aisle at a
checkout line so I would say they going
to be in trouble and so the commission
always has the right to reject right if
it's again they they make it look look
like a Tim's gummy bears over there um
if they make it look like that they can
say no this is not on this form is not
allowed right kind of thing so I had
another comment yes uh I had also that
we had extensive conversation about
adding as new Futures had suggested a
public health advisory committee and on
their memo on page three of their memo
number eight we agreed to add that
language what page where was let me see
you don't mind I gotta find where this
was in the bill oh it's a completely new
language yeah and it was around this
area which section will we added to I'll
just type
in
you yes this was in our October 30th
mimo that it was presented that it is a
way to just to address what you brought
up later if it we find that that amount
like the potency amounts or the serving
amount should be changed that the
commission could convene a public health
advisory commission to make these
suggestions guidelines only um and that
that was agreed to by the group it is
not meant to make any business
decisions I'm sorry Kate do the language
that so you gave us a memo dated
November
27th are c and d a a additions to what
you provided in the previous memo so
that today's my Mo something um
different based on the discussion last
week so just to wrap up what we were
talking about the public health advisory
commission that was something that this
committee discussed this commission
discussed let's put the I think I think
we're in agreement that'll be an
advisory commission but let's take that
and we'll figure out where to put it as
we get through the rest of the bill yeah
and we'll as again an item that we'll
add in there I think we all agree on an
advisory level type of committee um
that'll include law enforcement and
public health officials um
and uh but let's figure out we'll add it
as a at the end of the page now where do
we want to insert this kind of thing and
what what should it look like but the so
I think we agreed on my point is I guess
we agreed on number eight just the
creation of the advisory committee but I
think what new Futures is suggesting in
their memo of today is this additional
language about what the advisory
committee shall do correct well actually
this discussion is a yeah it's it is
related to the public health advisory
commission too so this was just um
discussion that happened last I think it
was on November 16th about whether
cannabis potency limit should be in
statute versus rulemaking there was a a
lot of conversation about that and even
a representative from Granite Leaf ATC
said they prefer to actually have it in
statute uh new Futures has said that all
along too so what I was just pointing
out was some suggested language from Dr
Lynn silver where she does put in a
potency amount for cannabis products and
then she had some other language about
you know that's the that's the limit for
three years and then and a group can
look at changing that I put in that
public health advisory commission
language as being that body because this
group had agreed on having that so that
just to me made the most sense that they
were the body that approved it so and
which section I'm sorry it which section
was potent limits is discussed on page
16 okay line 27 we'll get thank you so I
think we'll add advisory commission what
its role and responsibility is and who
will be who the makeup of that
commission it's not in here now but
we'll figure out where to add that into
the bill when we get to the end on big
policy ads that are not covered by the
current draft and lastly was the
medication um lock boxes that was agreed
on by the commission to S have the
franchise storees sell the medication um
lock boxes I'm not sure where that is in
here we'll see if we it's not in here in
the new draft it's not in here no none
of these things that we just discussed
are in
here therapeutic would need to be sold
in a lock with a lock box is that it's
not being sold that the it's that
anybody who is selling cannabis products
must also offer a lock box as part of
the condition of having a license that
you have to have a lock box for sale
don't have to sell it someone wants it
but they have to make it at that's a
requirement that has to be sold at the
franchise
stores I mean so I just wanted to point
out that not not only is that memo
Language new but everything that was
discussed from that November 30th looks
like it didn't make that this St right
thank you so um so we'll we'll take up
the the uh commission later anything
else on page
14 moving on to page
I think I only had one typo on letter A
the word that should have been added on
line 11 L um has there been any
discussion about having um a placard or
something at a at a retail facility like
I've see popped up everywhere now about
smoking I don't know every that's later
on in the bill that there is there is
some provision that talks about the fact
that there'll be regulatory mandatory
signage at at license
locations
so Chief back to our so Mr mik again go
on letter e did we decide that this was
drafted out about again this is talking
about um rule making authority of the
commission to to Draft rules and some
recommended um topics to start off with
again these are um including but not
limited to languages so that I just had
a call out on letter e about the
packaging and miners but I'm not sure we
need any more discussion on that
well is this the
area um where Dr jren would suggest so
uh
online
26 adding a comma such as Dr youngren
think
Miss so we're all set all set cool
anything else on
15 nope moving
on page
16 Senator L I think on page 16 we had
talked about adding a recall procedure
rule I don't see it that was going to be
um number nine it actually will end up
on page 17 but U we had number nine to
make sure that they Draft rules
regarding recalls and and notification
procedures is is there any any any
language you have to I can add it right
now so well so again on number seven we
got to change that to 30
months um
[Music]
number eight we got to change it to 30
months some reason we have 36 in there
is there you said you wanted to add a r
number eight though for recall is was
there any recall language that we had
nope again this is just the just saying
that as part of their rule this is all
under the rulemaking authority of of the
commission we want to make sure that as
part of rul making they addressed any
recall and notification Provisions
necessary for the retail outlets and
consumer
protection uh I had a note that number
on back on sorry page 16 and we got it
so we added a uh just that government
issued ID was I had note but it doesn't
look we do to change
anything Mr chair on the top of 17 that
should remain 36 months that's relative
to hemp discussion on hemp not cannabis
keep it at 36 so eight is eight is going
to stay at 36 thank you but seven is
going to go with a 30 and is we is the
liquor is not going to be regulating
him no they're going to make some
recommendations so on any possible
legislation written recommendation
I think this goes back to the
conversation again when I talked about
lonia Pumpkin Fest and that sign we saw
out that's a legal THC sold here and
that and letting and it was a hemp based
product and so how we regulate and how
we manage that give them Delta Delta 9
this Delta 8 Delta 9 which right now we
have uh uh a statute that bars it until
the end of this year so this is just a
continuation there was some question
whether we would want to sell it in the
stores or not so that's why we needed to
have the time to figure that
out all right so moving on um we'll
leave that at 36 months give you time to
regulate do if you make any
recommendations on line
25 um because we changed the definition
of a franchise cannabis retail outlet
and a cannabis retail outlet I'm going
to ask to strike and can the second one
that says and cannabis retail store and
I'll just read a franchise cannabis
retail Outlet shall include because we
have the they reference each other in
definition so it's kind of a
duplicative um I have a note on small
Roman numeral one or down on page 33
line 33 rather um whether or not I just
have a note this say possible penalty I
don't remember what we said there so
um so I I guess this is just regarding
the information material well this is
the handouts right so we want do we want
to include on a handout that's required
um for materials and this this is Sue
where we're talking about having signage
and that kind of stuff up is do we want
to make add that on that sign for the
risk of driving under the influence of
cannabis and the fact that doing so is
illegal you'll be subject to a fine of
right up to kind of language so that
people are aware of the severity and the
risk of that um but I would say Mr
chairman this would be one of the
instances where the Liquor Commission
could convene the committee to take up
the language of how they wanted the
posters put or what they wanted in the
store so we could certainly add that and
we'd be happy to do it which we don't
need it in statute though that's correct
okay um this is also discussing uh a
handout am I am I correct in reading
this was it saying handout uh we already
have us code has handouts that when you
get medications you know very specific
format easy to follow I would recommend
that that be looked at I will say for
the medical marijuana program the the
only thing that I have that's with it
not being in statute is that for the
medical marijuana program right now
there's there's not a lot of effective
handouts being given and there was
actually a bill to do that and the
people that fought against that the most
was Department of Health and Human
Services so and if I'm correct if I
understand this I don't even think that
there's a handout now so leaving it just
to a commission you know no offense but
sometimes unless it's in statute it
doesn't get done is that PO is the
poster ready yet I know there was a
poster that was supposed to be made yeah
like a oneye poster I think I think it
took about about two years is the poster
actually up in this theraputic
places okay so so again I I think what
we can add for language in here uh again
I think this is one of those things that
can fall underneath the advisory Council
for for public health and law
enforcement to add his handout and have
input with the Liquor Commission on the
the making of his handout so we can add
under the duties of the uh commission
that they'll work with reviewing and
reviewing the handouts out of the going
out so we have a public health and a law
enforcement uh input into that process
well all I'm saying is unless the
handout require IR ments are put in the
statute it probably won't get done
timely I think to that point if the
poster is not done yet which it doesn't
since no one can answer that with
absolute certainty which makes me
believe it's not done yet that poster
should have been done two years ago so I
think putting it in there and I I'm
confident that won't be a
problem making a hand out it says that
it could be identical to what the poster
is but that post needs to
exist so so the only other comment
change I had in this area was uh on line
D I had a note about chronic cannabis
use disorder including some sort of
language relative to that on on under
letter D TR I recognize um Pro uh
problematic usage of cannabis and how to
obtain appropriate treatment um and
again I just have a note says chronic
cannabis use disorder and including some
sort of language around that doctor so I
think that we had just said how to
recognize cannabis use disorder and set
up problematic use of cannabis since
that's what the medical diagnosis would
be and how to obtain appropriate
treatment and
services so it'll read how to recognize
um cannabis use disorder and how to
obtain appropriate services and
treatment if we can just backtrack in in
on page 17 so where the franchise cams
retail LM on line 28 it shall include
information handle designed by the
commission now it's in consultation with
the Department Department means DHHS so
I want to put in consultation with the
advisory
committee I guess my my point is that
the holdup still may still happen so do
we want to require the consultation with
the
department so I guess the question is
again if we're gonna if we're going to
establish an advisory committee I think
we should have one point of contact not
multiple points of contact so we're
going to go back if if if that language
and I think you're what L darl what line
were you looking at I'm looking at line
29 on page 17 and that doesn't mean
there can't be consultation but
requiring it under statute I think might
be I think that's that's the point that
was kind of raised so actually it's 26
on your on on page 17 on the print out
where it says informational handout
designed by the Commission in
consultation with the department and in
this case the department means DHS the
question is do we want to change that to
the advisory Council yeah don't we want
to remove DHHS completely completely and
and get stuff done immediately so let's
change it does everybody think it should
be the advisory Council the Cannabis
advisory Council that's being
created yes
no I I will add to that that uh
according to that handout that I was
referring to it was the therapeutic
cannabis oversight medical oversight
board was not on board with doing this
handout either so I'm just letting you
know we're we're requiring it so I think
we're okay there right we're saying
they'll make it available a design one
the only question is who has input into
what that handout looks like at this
point do we want it to be liquor and
DHHS or do we want it to be liquor and
the new Advisory board that we're
creating the Cannabis Advisory Board
that's the question I think right now
we're sitting around okay and no handout
they can't sell so they I'm sure so
let's go Frank and then doctor I mean I
think it makes I mean it defer to you
but I think it makes sense to have it as
The Advisory board with the commission
and I just um can we Circle back who is
on The Advisory Board again we'll we'll
work that out but there public Health
officials law enforcement and Department
of Health and Services I have a comment
doesn't um the ATC the HHS already have
an Advisory
Board don't you already have an Advisory
board so if they already have the
Advisory Board then I just say take this
away from The Liquor Commission this is
the atcs are the ones whove got the high
potency product they should get this
poster made and they can use their their
Advisory Board and get it done and I
don't think they won make poster was
should have been made two years ago we
can we can write in the statute right
here that the HHS has to get it done
they have to approve it get the
consultation get it done we back up one
second guys so I'm not going to go
backwards in history I'm going to go
forwards in history right so let's look
at what we're going to do not what what
what we had in the past right and so
again the question becomes if we're
taking away the
management again if you're an ATC you're
going to stay with DHHS and that
Advisory Board applies and you go do the
ATC thing but if you're going to be a
retail store and you're going to then I
think we need the regulatory stuff to
stay with Department of Health and Human
Services and we establish a cannabis
advisory commission underneath health
and underneath liquor and let them work
with liquor for the purposes of this
handout I think that's the easiest way
rather than go between departments
because we've taken away the regulatory
control of a store if an ATC chooses to
become a for-profit retail store that
sells both therapeutic and and Retail
product um we've taken away that the
regulat oversight of that building or
that facility and put it in the hands of
liquor so I I my recommendation is to
just in consultation with the Cannabis
Advisory Board and we'll figure out what
that board again that's the last item
we're going to go back to is going to
say board or
commission whatever either Miss
commission cannabis advisory
commission
CAC this is the public health advisory
committee yeah Public Health advisory
committee which we we agreed upon
creating yep then you know we'll deal
with that at the end but I'm just saying
that I just think Mr creation have been
on vacation when he creation of hand out
we want to leave in Liquor's hands not
have two different agencies going back
and forth trying to figure out what it
looks like and we we established a
commission that includes Public Health
officials and law enforcement to help
B sorry my daughter's going I do say you
better take that no I just silenced it
she she's used to that
um all right so
um we're on
18 catch up here go back where we were
um any
[Music]
other so I had a note that on um
line hold on on line 35 of on page
18 I had a note um
that um the Del up to two hours was a a
we agreed to strike
that and just say um caution when eaten
or swallow the toxic effects of this
product may be delayed and not put a
timeline in there it's always striking
uh up to two hours maybe
delayed yes yep
okay
y 18 here on the
caution
um on the top of
19 on a FR okay so we're moving on to uh
318 F9 um franchise fee imposed yeah so
we were talking about the total gross
revenue and I had something about oh
right because we were talking about
minus accessories and paraphernalia we
didn't want to
impose so I think again the discussion
Point here was around cannabis
accessories because we have stores that
currently are not licensed facilities
that sell cannabis accessories and we
Define what a cannabis accessory is so
the question is if we're charging a
retail store if a if a licensed retail
store marijuana retail store cannabis
retail store is selling accessories
should that be taxed or not taxed to
make it on par with
non-licensed I did yeah
um so the question is
um chair do we think we should exclude
can
accessories two just one quick thing on
line four we're going to just strike the
word tax we have the word tax in good
yeah so that will be fee right and our
discussion on our discussion on that was
in order to make it in order to make it
fair we have to do what one way or the
other not tax the franchisees or tax the
people that are selling it now
so so's what's the consensus the
consensus is just to strike the tax
component of the um accessories in all
instances whether it's a licensed retail
store or or a gen General retail store
yes that's the right in okay don't have
a sales
tax so will sounds like that's a
consensus of the committee so we'll add
in here a language that just says that
cannabis um accessories and Par yeah
grow it'll be basically a franchise fee
on a monthly gross total less the sale
of cannabis
accessories yeah
excluding the sale of cannabis I I just
have to add for the record that this is
just word play what's that it's a tax
this is just word play yeah I
understand so again so it'll say a
franchise fee on the month a franchise
fee on the monthly total gross revenue
excluding the sale of cannabis
accessories deriv from this or you could
say uh actually the way it's worded it's
not bad a franchise fee on the monthly
total gross revenue derived from the
sale of cannabis and cannabis products
but not on the sale it's just another
way to do it sure we'll put it right
there
excluding yeah yeah so right after the
word cannabis products we just want to
add excluding the sale of cannabis
accessories by the franchise is
everybody good with
that moving on um just know that there's
a couple places here where we again have
the we have two different definitions of
retail store and the language and I'm
just Daryl's going through and just
striking that second reference all at
every place that's found um so in in
this line on the draft page on page 19
we have the same thing franch franchise
retail franchise cannabis retail outlet
and cannabis retail store we're just
striking in cannabis retail store
everywhere we find it where we're
defining them both yep um all right
where were we
um no
May chair one couple of quick changes on
the bottom if on 318 F12 line
31 the commission shall require all C us
establishments to utilize we'd like the
word put in an electronic inventory
tracking system so everybody does it the
same our inventory is one way that makes
sense and then on line
35 um and the sale of cannabis and
cannabis products from seedling to sale
shall enable separation of tracking that
way we've got it from beginning to
end
okay so again so we're going to that
sentence will read starting on line 34
the system shall ensure an accurate
accounting of the pro of the production
processing and sale of cannabis and
cannabis products from seedling to sale
and shall enable yep correct thank
you I have a question yes on the trans
transferring of
cannabis um between cannabis
establishments how will law enforcement
that stops a truck of marijuana know
it's
tracked it's a legal grow quote unquote
or an illegal
grow with the electronic tracking will
law enforcement have access to that
tracking I wouldn't see why not I I
don't think that that would be a problem
I think it would be anyone that anyone
within the law enforcement agencies that
wanted to see that tracking would have
the availability to see it our our folks
would certainly have it and able to
share it with anybody that would be 247
that's correct thank you yeah Mr Malik I
also I assume that the licing component
of this there'll be some sort of card
right or some sort of placard some sort
of something they have to have if
they're if they're acting as
transporting the product between
cultivator the manufacturer manufacturer
to distribution distribution to um
retail to store all anybody who's doing
that activity will have some sort of
card or some sort of way of proving I'm
I'm like to do this much like when you
go into a restaurant today there's a
requirement of a license on the wall
That's signed by the commission that
would have to be at the establishment
where the product was cultivated
manufactured and in those vehicles that
was that were transporting it so in
theory the driver will have some sort
of so all right um all right so 13 is
where we start talking about enactment
Clauses and there were some changes in
here
um so the first change is on line two
and just say at the banial election we
got rid of the held in November of 24 we
didn't want dates on
there um the next change was the second
half of the sentence um and getting rid
of where it says shall we allow the
operation of count establishment within
our city or town and then we struck the
whole second question from the word and
all the way through to to um city or
town is that
everybody remembering that the same way
I
am I wasn't here I wasn't here for that
so take
word so um we had another strike out
here is if the majority of the qualified
voters present in voting in the
municipal signal their approval for
operation of a count of establishment
then the Cannabis establishment may
start I had struck all that because I
think it
was duplicative once they've approved it
there's no date that's
necessary but I had that I had that
whole thing all the way to July 1 of 25
struck on my copy that we agreed to
strike that as
well okay and then we left the rest of
the provision
alone so there are significant changes
is on
14 yeah so we're also just striking all
the way to Jo from from there all the
way to
here um all right
um so again I as I read
this
um no casile shop
operate um we had we had a second I
wrote 171 col1 for some reason insert
but I don't know what that was so I
don't I don't
remember so Senator abbis did you just
make these changes on your own were
there was this agreed on by the
commission well are you talking about R
numeral two 14 no for we're starting on
line uh 29 that's ran numeral one
section F14 uh one has talking about
distances where you can operate a
cannabis related product location that
was not discussed I'm I'm sure come up
today so in consultation with many of
the people that have been reviewing this
my understanding this language is a will
be needed to get it over the finish
line so it's
uh well here I'm not saying that I it's
it's my first choice I think 2000 ft was
I was okay with that but when I say that
this may hit a road
block it might not make it over the
Finish Line well I mean I that may be
true but this commission is making
recommendations about what the
commission thought was appropriate you
know there will be
political uh conversations which is why
you know Senator Lang had suggested at
the very beginning that folks will
provide comments but I don't I don't
this is a this is a change in policy
that this commission didn't
discuss I thought we had talked about
putting it on in par with liquor I think
it was 250 ft right so I just looked up
the RS right so I remember why I wrote
insert 71 uh 177 colon one and it talks
about the state liquor stores it says
the commission may lease purchase and
equip in the name of the state such
store state-owned Warehouse warehouses
supplies as defined in blah blah blah
and other material goods and services
are necessary for incidental to or
related to the operation of Liquor
Commission retail and wholesale
operators the commission may lease in
the name of the state space for State
stores for the purpose of installing an
automatic teling machines no newly
estblished established state store shall
operate within 200 ft of any public or
private school church chapel or Parish
house so I think we were talking about
adding that language about 200 feet in
here so it's consist so state liquor
stores and State marijuana stores are
are on par um and then have the fight
out you know again call that out as a
area of discussion for the policy
committee to have and I understand
Daryl's point that this may be a
roadblock for some people um you know if
it's not at least as big or or small
um I I would say that if we're going to
establish a new standard beyond what we
use already for liquor stores then that
should be a separate policy discussion
by the policy committee so let's go to
let's hold on let's go to we're gonna go
to Dave then Tim and the chief we're so
we're tasked with doing with coming up
with recommendations that we feel would
be the safest and the most efficient in
all those things for the State of New
Hampshire so I don't think 200 feet for
a selling marijuana really protects a
school with a high school you have a
high school 200 feet away it's you you
walk out the front door you walk a block
you're right there and talking about an
enticement every time kids walk by it to
go to school so I I think it is
necessary to to have it um and I think
it makes sense where where it says uh
you know a half a mile with 50 thou a
mile with less than 50,000 residents and
a half mile with um for over that
because it because it would make it
makes sense because with uh you know you
have cities you you lodger like take
Manchester for instance you have at
least I think it's down to 12 but you
have 12 elementary schools you have you
have the uh junior high schools and then
you have four high schools so I think
that half a
mile you know makes a makes a uh makes a
provision to to at least allow it if
Manchester decides to do that so Tim you
know I just want to say you know we
we've pretty much removed every other
guideline protecting the kids for the
most part this this commission should
not make it 250 feet that's that's CL
that's clown
like I'm not not either way I'm I'm just
saying with the existing laws for state
schools and we have the same protections
of beer for alcohol right we only kids
drinking beer 16 year olds so that's why
we set a 200 foot limit but now now
we're going to change it and create an
increased limit for other specific
product that's all I'm I'm talking about
consistency in in messaging Chief I will
say that the Chiefs are in favor of the
one mile but with that being said if
we're going to look at the
alcohol um limits why are we bringing it
down to preschool Elementary and
secondary let's just say schools so it
includes colleges we've heard testimony
that up to age 25 it's going to affect
your brain development
why are we going to allow
colleges well again under under the C
under the current 1771 it doesn't
specify it says schools it just says
schools period which would include
College I agree so again so we went to
the 1771 language it's um shall be no no
no estate store shall be operated within
200 feet of any public private school
church chapel or Parish house would be
the language the question is whether we
agree with that and we can argue about
the distance if we want um or we can use
the distance as an addendum note um make
it consistent with current law and then
have it as an addendum note of policy
committee needs to discuss how far away
this is so um let's do Frank and then
and then
sue uh thank you I think that makes
sense to have it you know on par with
existing law um I think one other thing
this is more of a question do we know
what it currently exists with regard to
atc's and any distance requirements from
schools others ask somebody in the
audience that might know maybe Mike you
might know do we have a distance
requirement for ATC to be away from
schools
churches in the report that we put out
we can put that the the policy issues
are not agreed upon by you know that's
whether you
support if you're a yes vote on the on
the report but it doesn't mean you
support all the policies like this so
would be I I just want to add in we're
trying to make this equivalency to the
liquor laws but the reality is this is a
federally illegal drug and liquor is not
a federally illegal substance so we
really we really I think that that
actually justifies having two sets of
stand
so would would the argu would we agree
that if we oh sorry Tim go ahhe you know
he brings up a great point over here F
finally I agree with Frank we should
follow the existing law and follow the
existing law of at least a thousand feet
so I I'm okay with that that's just
where I was going to go so we okay with
making the limit equal to what is the
current limit under the thcs I can I
just explain one
thing if there's certain things I'm
aware I'm aware of that are deal
breakers and certain things that are not
I if this language is I'm just telling
you it's not it's part it's part of a
compromise and if we're going to
compromise there's a lot of people
compromising in different directions
here this is one of them I'm not saying
it's it turns out to be problematic it's
one of those things that a future
legislator could always John then David
okay as someone who sits on a policy
committee I think a thousand is the
right answer okay thank you CH I I think
we we we had a great deal discussion on
M
to to young people and how we have to uh
we have to really do our best to make
sure that doesn't happen but by allowing
even a thousand feet I believe
especially at a high school I think
that's the best marketing you could ever
have for a marijuana shop where kids
have to go byy it and they see the signs
in the whatever in the in the windows
and I've never seen a uh I've never seen
a Liquor Commission I mean a a liquor
outlet Maybe I'm Wrong uh they were
school before
so again we already
allow U therapeutic cannabis atc's
within a th000 feet that's the current
law um so my my recommendation and if
the committee will go along with that is
to use that same footage so we're not
setting a brand new standard for a
different type of uh function and then
let anybody who has an objection to the
thousand feet can write an addendum that
Daryl can add to the report that'll say
um this this foot limit was not uh
recommended I don't think we need to do
it because we'll have a million of those
this report's going be will'll be 2,000
Pages I'm just telling you you change
this the whole the whole thing sen Lang
how many how many atcs are there in the
state of New Hampshire seven right so
what we're really talking about is we're
actually talking about a whole crud ton
of pot shops popping up which is not the
same thing as 4,000 feet around four
atc's so I I I think that using the ATC
standard is willfully inadequate for the
volume of of stores that are going to be
trying to establish themselves in the
state under the franchise let's do this
let's Dave did did I get to you I
apologize your mic was still on okay all
those in favor of using the ATC standard
to move forward raise your
hand all those want to use the liquor
standard raise your
hand all those that want to use the
what's written in here raise your
hand
okay all right so looks like the
consensus is we'll leave the language as
it is um and then anybody who wants to
write an theendum can write in theendum
to the bill uh as a as a as a call out
note for the policy committee can we
change it to schools versus preschools
elementaries
Etc so do you want to use the question
is and again I I so we're going to be a
little bit of parody do you want to use
the language that's in
1771 which is um um so we would change
property line property line
of any public private school church
chapel or Parish house
yes would would that include a preschool
yes public school thank you oh no well
yeah private not all preschools are
private what about the I'm sorry just
I'm looking at the LI the we're only
talking about for municipalities with
less Le than 50,000 residents and then
half mile for municipalities with more
than 50,000
resents so I understand that would apply
to cities like Manchester rash it's more
it's more
condensed so we to leave existing
language we're just going to change that
to include the language from
1771 on what type of facilities you have
to be a distance from um to make it more
inclusive so if you add those those
other uh give the institution I'm not
saying it's a bad idea in general but
the the one mile or an half mile is
taken into consideration only schools so
if you add other things to that you may
cancel out everything so I don't know I
don't know that's are
intent well that's why I wouldn't add
everything I would just leave schools
because I think that's all right what
that distance was let's do again so the
question is do we want to leave it we're
going to have two different stances
we'll take a quick vote on by the
committee the first stance is to leave
the language that is currently in there
it says pre-existing public or private
preschool Elementary or secondary school
and municipalities or do we change it to
say um instead of that provision
preschool that that says instead any
public or private school church chapel
or Parish house so everyone's in favor
of the existing language raise your
hand everybody wants to use the liquor
store model that includes public private
schools churches
those things raise your
hand there's a lot of churches that have
schools in them so so again so it looks
like we're going to use the liquor
language to for the loc for the
definition of what product properties
are subject to the foot the restriction
on distance what's the RSA so I can
reference 177 one it's right here here's
the
language also we're adding striking the
any public private school church chapel
or Parish house all right moving on 177
col one
one uh 318
F15
um only thing I had was in here we were
adding the word license throughout the
entire thing so it said um from a
licensed cannabis cultivation facility
delivering a transfer a licensed
cannabis so everywhere where we're
talking about a facility we want to make
it absolutely clear we're talking about
licensed product licensed
locations
it's through the whole section right so
it's one a anywhere it says like a
whatever's an actual facility
is all right
um can you uh can you just give
me on uh page 20 is there a reason for
the double negative on uh section 15 why
does it say following act shall not be
illegal why not just say following act
shall be legal I mean it it's almost
like it's I just wondered if there's a
reason it's written that
way yeah not be illegal means it's legal
so you can just say shall be legal be
legal like double double you okay with
that you know it's a little conv instead
of not be illegal just say shall be
legal shall be legal bear with
me what 3
15 be instead of saying shall not shall
not be illegal just say shall be
illegal word not all
[Music]
right
page 21
we're moving on to page
22 I had here that
um the Chiefs we're going to come back
with information on
this all right
um so talking about we're under
F16 proof of purchases
identity was there anything here we need
to
change Chief I had that the we just
wanted to make sure it was
consistent I just had some note that
said liquor license and I remember what
what we were saying at the top under the
title I think we were just trying to
make it equivalent to alcohol and so
we're just yeah I think you need um I
need to say can not just sale of
cannabis cannabis and cannabis products
it's a little bit of different
cannabis cannabis products or cannabis
accessories anything else under proof of
ID
identity uh moving on to
17 um I think we had pretty good
discussion on this relative to sting
operations versus normal
enforcement
um and it's a violation in sting
operation nor it's a misdemeanor in
normal
enforcement and regular
enforcement and again this is a
violation to the licensed against the
licensed operator who misdemeanor
against a licensed operator not the
individual is there a difference in
definition it says cannabis
paraphernalia versus canab this
accessory I know you know they could be
more than that I think parap little
broader but we need to
put accessories under
8-f
117 so cannabis accessories and cannabis
paraphernalia are defined on page three
Roman numeral 3 so we have a pretty good
definition yeah but it doesn't include
accessories um
318 d F 17 I'm just going to add
cannabis accessories
paraph paraphernalia is there which I
think includes accessories but I would
are you talking about 16 or
17 17 and my Lin oh you just want to add
you just want to say cannabis cannabis
products cannabis accessories or can
cannabis paraphernalia okay everybody
okay with that
parhelia same it's in the same it's one
of those duplicative
definitions
all right um in on on ran numeral 2 line
26 um I had an addition on here that
says except as allow permitted by RSA
126x I had the same right so this is
people under the age of 21 who have a
medical card um are allowed they are not
going to be subject to that
where where are you right now Roman new
uh line on the new bill line 28 right
here nothing is trapped shall to
transfer blah BL someone under 21 except
as provided for so right under under
this section right here at the end of
there um we just say we need to add
except as provided for by RSA 126x
chapter
126x
okay next
page
um if I could I just want to make sure I
understand I'm reading correctly on
37 uh what what page or what line 23
page 23 line 37 it looks like uh in the
case of the rental or residential
dwelling a landlord shall not prohibit
the possession of cannabis or the
consumption of cannabis by non-smoking
means unless never I'll just keep
reading I think I'm just getting stuck
on
that so again it it allows for a
landlord to still prohibit smoking but
not prohibit consumption by any other
means so you you can they can prohibit
smoking and vaping but they can't stop
you from eating an edible it's the short
first we want to leave that in there
yeah I'm okay with that
it's over
tacking it's yeah one of those things
where if you're using Edibles your
landlord to the point that your landlord
finds out you're I'm not really sure
what you're
doing land might also say you can't
drink
in I think the difference between
smoking and vaping is the residue right
so you don't if I take an edible I'm not
going to get residue all over my walls
you ever walked on someone's apartment
that smokes right so again I think the
landlord has a right to limit the damage
to their existing property I mean you
can limit whether someone has
pets why don't we strike this landlord
section why I'd like to strike it seems
like a odd to legislate that seems
odd what I
would recommend so you want to
strike
um all
of
really
all yeah if if there's not something in
statute that actually allows the
landlord to say whether or not they want
to prevent cannabis smoking on their
property then does that open them up to
liability of getting sued for
discrimination I think you can put it in
your lease you put it in your lease just
like you know pets
some right but could somebody challenge
that legally saying well there's no you
know there's it's a discrimination
against Canabis smokers that's not a
protected
class
like L could say no alcohol in my could
they put that in their lease I mean the
only the only place I know where they
can do that is if it's like a sober
living facility but absent that I'm not
I mean this is I don't know I'd have to
look I'm not familiar with that it's
it's contract it's a lease is a contract
you you put in there what you if you
don't want your attendant having a large
dog or a dog over a certain weight or
any dog at all you put it in there m Mr
J but I'm just saying this is a kind of
like an awkward regulation of the
landlord I just it doesn't need to be in
there by any means especially in what
the charge of the commission is I I
would strike it
um so are we talking about striking just
four no leave the four
M Mr
chair all right so you wanted to strike
letter A all of letter
A then and then that includes a little
one Sue and then Tim well I would just
say that this we're not really talking
about a dog or or some something that's
already a known factor for landlords I I
do believe since this is sort of a new
territory for a lot of people landlords
might need a little bit of that top top
cover and
statute and and and I also agree because
in our last house session we heard
people testifying on the house floor
that their religion was doing drugs this
was part of their religion so that's a
protected class um so the you can go
watch the tapes we had Representatives
testifying to that so it it doesn't
listen it doesn't we we have to protect
we have to protect the landord slow down
so if we strike um a and leave B right B
still says this chapter shall not
prevent a landlord from prohibiting
cannabis smoking or cannabis
cultivation um I don't know we need
cultivation because cultivation is now a
licensed function so it can't they can't
they can't allow it anyway um but um are
we okay if we choose to strike a just
leaving renumbering B and
C
yes all those in favor of striking a um
signify by raising your
hand all right so we'll we'll strike a
um and then B becomes a
and C becomes
B all right we good on that section
moving on to to 19 enforcement of
contracts I have no notes on this it was
accepted by
everybody this next one will be a
interesting conversation regarding
licensure part of me feels we should
just strike the entire thing you're
talking about nondiscrimination the
non-discrimination
um activities and prior convictions part
of me wants to strike the whole thing
we're walking into a giant Minefield of
licenses and and professional licenses
and state licenses Federal licenses and
I'm not sure you know we
should I agree
comments Chief my thought is if we chose
or choose at this point to ignore it
we're setting up so many agencies for
failure it it's just not right I think
that you have to address this with the
lers school bus drivers police officers
people carrying weapons security
guards there's limits there's Federal
limits and I think that you have to look
at those and address them now versus
down the road when it
happens right Senator Whitley yeah I
just I didn't know if the Attorney
General had any comments that we had
sort of asked him to touch base yep
absolutely now thank you for that so
brought it back we spoke internally
about these Provisions outside of my
area of expertise I don't have any
recommended language at this point just
given the complexities of this issue uh
may be appropriate for a placeholder
just as was discussed earlier given all
of the uh the considerations at play
here what I can tell you in this is more
in the legal world as for attorneys
ethical rules you know when when states
have started to allow Recreation or
whatnot we ran to dilemma like we're not
as a lawyer we can't Advocate or give
someone advice to violate the law when
there's a conflict between state and
federal what do we do and the recommend
the guidelines from you know most of the
uh the um State bars what they came out
with basically if you would advise them
to comply with state law you know you
just have to advise them in part of the
process you are violating federal law
which is pretty easy to do but for here
this has to do with whether you know
we're going to impact professional
licenses or not or occupations are we
going to deal with that at the state
level um I
think you know I understand some federal
laws like if you have a CDL this could
be a
problematic but are we are we going to
tackle that right now with this this
commission so let let's go to Tim and
then PR you know I just have a question
from my colleagues and everybody sitting
out there and everybody at home U raise
your hand if you actually want your
kids's school bus driver being allowed
to get high while they're driving your
kids
and I think the answer should be no for
every single one of you and we should
regulate that yeah but I think just
that's up to the employer on to Frank de
Frank um I I think this section is
important I think we heard from
testimony this morning that there has to
be a NE I mean it's important to have
some requirement that there's a Nexus
between the denial of lure and the the
action that the person engaged in so in
this case smoking marijuana or using
marijuana I think section 10 or part 10
unlik line 30 on page 26 gives clear uh
ability of uh employers to um uh Pro uh
to punish or to discipline individuals
who engage in uh actions that are either
negligence or um forget the term we used
not malpractice but um there's a new
term I think that was circulated this
morning obviously operating a vehicle is
prohibited under DUI laws but also
clearly here operating and be on 36 is
also prohibited um so I don't think
that's um I think that concern is
addressed in many other places um I do
think it's important that practically
speaking people use marijuana and it's
important not to deny lure uh for
something when there's no clear Nexus to
their use of marijuana and their ability
to conduct their employment I will say
in lines 8 n of page 25 Pride conviction
for a nonviolent can cannabis offense it
does not involve distribution to minors
uh yeah we could probably that doesn't
really eliminate the drug kingpin shall
we say but so we can probably make that
stronger but
otherwise I just leaving it in so here's
my concern is around section six of this
bill except as provided the section
neither the state nor any political
subdivisions May discriminate against a
person in hiring termination or any term
or condition of employment or otherwise
penalize a person in employment or
Contracting if the Discrimination is
based on any of the on either of the
following right so engaging a lawful
activity so smoking or consuming
marijuana right a prior conviction for
nonviolent offense which is fine right
I'm okay with doing way with past
convictions but then the last one is
testing positive so again state trooper
police officer um fireman um anybody who
test positive by this the town can't
fire them if that's the only reason for
doing it they can't do a random blood
test find out that they test positive
and say you're
terminated that's problematic if that's
a condition of employment so how do we
exclude that and how do we deal with
that because now we're talking about
State we're talking about Municipal and
County and state employees our
correctional officers our again firemen
policemen
um I think sen Whitley so I think in
this area I I agree that so I'm sort of
thinking of middle ground because I do
agree that this is worthy of
conversation and incl in the overall
topic but I think it's complicated
enough that we're not going to solve it
today so perhaps a note here that you
know the committee there is consensus
around the need to have some
conversation about non-discrimination
but you know essentially we ran out of
time to go through the details I was
just thinking instead of it says
distribution to miners just have it say
distribution I think that basically if
you were illegally I'm talking sort of
globally about this section about this
whole section this non-discriminatory
for employment purposes which is what
we're all talking about in general and
there's some specific call outs here um
so I I that I have just have concerns I
don't know how to address them again
like law enforcement fire my my concern
is that those kind of you know um people
who are subject to drug testing are
state employees and test
positive right why I guess my question
is are are State Police are state
employees drug tested anywhere in this
are
they we're talking here about employment
and hiring right so again I know in
hiring that's not an uncommon practice
again I got I got tested by the New
Hampshire Electric uh NHC just go work
in it was a requirement of testing right
so um and if I pop positive does that
mean they still have to give me the
job or would they be discriminate
against me because I'm doing a legally
function a legal subject so do I now
have a case against them for
discrimination I don't think it's
discrimination because it's not a
protected class everyone keeps you
throwing that word around discrimination
because it's in here may not
discriminate I I know but it's it's
using it out of context I mean
discrimination applies you know it's
gender religion race Frank that type of
stuff um I I can do my home uh research
and get it back obviously not for
purposes of today but for the policy
debates this session I believe like just
from band The Box work in the past I
think there are carve outs for certain
uh employment types like law enfor Etc
that have a different criteria um and
carve outs from uh some of these lure
issues so we could get that to the
policy committees but if it would be you
know okay with everyone to kind of leave
the concept in here understanding that I
think as you mentioned Senator Lang perc
that seems to be the hang-up issue on
Line 39 and we can get back to folks
with some ideas from other states is
there any objection though with if you
go on page 25 lines it's 36 37 same
thing same page on lines 8 n to just
strike two minors and just have that say
distribution so if
you I'm okay with
that so everybody okay so the idea is
just again any any possession with
intent to sell that's that's you know on
your record is still valid doesn't have
to be just a minor it's any any
possession with intent to sell in case
conviction per
all right I'm sorry was there consensus
reached I'm sort of going back to the
entirety of the section I don't think
there is and like I I'm I would like to
see I I don't know how to deal with um
section six which is my big concern
about Municipal towy you know and state
government um
employment you know concerns so we could
just I'm just saying for if you just
globally we could instead of you know
this is just a thought we could just say
globally for Section 20 for F20 that you
know there was consensus reached that
the conversation of about
non-discrimination is important in the
context of employment uh licensing Etc
but we didn't have the capacity or the
time to get into the details just
retaining the
concept what we would need to do is just
put in the bill as a study committee to
create to have a policy for next
year that's the way we normally do it
again so also remember that we have a
30mon push out on this so there is more
time to deal with we could do a
commission you know separate bill for a
commission on this topic and let them
delve into what the the detail is on
their license or public license we could
just strike the section in in its place
or we could leave it put the study
committee in this section huh you just
WR this section you just say no you want
to add the commission you add add the
study commission right now in in the
bill that it it it will T you know for
another year deadline for legislation
for for 20 26 so that would go after
section six well no I think he's going
to leave it as it's going to be actually
F20 the whole of F20 will be we'll
establish commission the study and it's
everything that's in this section
therefore make it easier when they put
it in the statute right that make sense
to everybody yes so again so the idea
being that instead of using prescriptive
dialogue in here what we're going to say
is that the legislature will establish
the study commission and there'll can
make up the study commission toy to
discuss um discrimination in state level
blah blah blah blah blah and allow and
it'll cover these topics and it's all
the topics that's listed in 20 yep okay
so including uh Medical Care yes okay so
all the topics that listed in 20 so
we're just going to form a study
committee to study everything that's in
20 in this bill so we can figure out the
proper place for it again we have 30
months before you know as an end go goal
so we'll have some time for that the
ultimate punt yep all right uh moving on
to 21 uh data collection related to cans
legalization
regulation um Becka you were in charge
you were chairing at this point I have
no changes on this so you had note here
nonenal
okay okay so
line that's the old bill right if we're
looking at the new
[Music]
will I'm not sure I made there's any
changes what she's looking right now
page 27 of the new
bill so yeah the bottom of 26 top of
27 every
two okay no sorry the bottom of page 26
of the new
bill um this was a privacy concern we
wanted to include here to ensure that's
non-identifiable information so
at so includes okay so it on the bottom
of the page 42 after the word
includes um non-identifiable P personal
or individual Baseline
data so right here under the word
includes
non-identifiable
personal individual
data or individual Baseline data
personal or
individual everybody got that so bottom
of page 26 line 42 it'll read um no
later than six months after the
effective date of this chapter and every
two years they after the department of
safety information analysis and of drug
monitoring initiative shall produce and
publish a report that includes
non-identifiable personal or individual
Baseline data and the most blah blah
blah so will any of this uh in the
section of uh F21 will it include um
Hospital
reporting for any sort of uh acute care
cannabis use disorder issues will will
that information be gleaned from
hospital uh intake I don't know that
this includes that let me finish reading
the whole thing okay
so it says what what the report will
includes but not limited to is high
school graduation rates Youth and adult
rates of alcohol cannabis and illegal
drug use rates of maladaptive use of
cannabis rates of alcohol abuse opioid
use abuse rates the number of type of
Youth and adult convictions for cannabis
offenses and the rates of individuals
needing but not receiving substance um
that should be substance use disorder
cannabis use disorder treatment my my
only point is that that if you really
want some actual data that you would get
it from the emergency
rooms Mr chair would you agree Jim do
you have a point on that I also think
maybe we should include data from
traffic
fatalities that people are I I think
that's another
section so we're going to make one
change to that action it's just going to
well we're going to add the Privacy data
and we're going to change that but not
receiving cannabis use disorder
treatment right C uh cannabis fund
established okay so again yeah I thank
you excuse me thank you Mr chair um we
discussed and reached consensus on this
section um referring back to the new
Futures memo dated October 30th we
agreed to add the
language uh
in on page two number
six let me take a look at
that so this is under Roman numeral this
one you talk about right Roman numeral
five so this is under Roman numeral five
um the recommendation is
and then
replace 10% shall be allocated the
substance abuse prevention treatment and
Recovery Fund established under so
instead of the
um
numeral
sorry so it's just a reallocation of the
funds instead of it going to um so we're
talking about after dedu the appropriate
charges to the fund the cost for
administering the
cost of the remaining funds under B um
we're looking at section the small three
on page 28 it's about that 10% or 25
million whichever is less shall be
credited to the substance abuse
prevention treatment and Recovery
Fund and instead the language wants to
read
um 10 10% shall be allocated as subance
Abuse Prevention and Recovery Fund
established under and get rid of all the
other language yep and then also in
regard to Roman numeral four let me make
sure we're okay with three so instead of
all this other language that's in here
about all the different types of
treatment everything else we're putting
the money into the substance abuse
treatment and Recovery Fund for for
expans and we have language we went over
already talking about the dispersement
of that fund for what what treatment
purposes and everything else my
understanding is it'll be a separate
fund from the existing alcohol fund but
it will still be administered so to
speak by the treatment fund by the
commission y Governor's commission
Governor's commission not yeah not so so
does that make sense to everybody so it
should be so just I'm going to make the
one recommendation that it say um second
let me grab
it it's that we will keep the 10% or 25
million whichever is less
language as far as the amount goes we
did have a discussion uh based
on the speak couple the speakers that we
uh had here that uh 10% really isn't
really doesn't cover the the cost $4
million roughly what's that $4
million that would be the
number 4 million
based on our base again I'm going back
to 1598 and discussion we had about we
did this whole calculation based on
other states and per capita use and
comparing that to New Hampshire for per
capita use uh like Colorado and those
other states and the number we came up
with um 15% of that is around
3875 million in Revenue to the state and
if we allocate 10% to that it's rough
$3.8 million
roughly
darl thinks the number is going to be
sen abis thinks the number is going to
be much higher than that most I'm taking
more conservative the fiscal notes that
I've seen on the other uh recreational
Cannabis bills didn't really have any
significant uh consideration for out
estate consumers where I think a lot of
our retail markets you name it a lot of
it's funded or by out of state consumers
so on a conservative approach I know
again Daryl thinks the num is going to
be much higher I'm being a little more
conservative doing the number much lower
um but the rough idea of 15% was $ 38.7
million in Revenue to the state and you
would get 10% of that to the fund which
is $38 million would go for subance
abuse and treatment so we're looking at
little Roman numeral 3 correct
99 and that's going to be in your
calculation will be a number that's
going to be around four million cor
right conservative
number because that right now right now
for alcohol coming from the alcohol
funds which is about 10% it comes out
basically about $10 million that we get
and that does not come close to
covering the harm that's caused by
alcohol where it's it's we when it is
fully funded there still isn't enough
funding to go around so now we're we're
going to introduce um cannabis and we're
going to say we're looking at just $4
million well again that that's the
extremely conservative side of that
number Dr do Dr Silver had indicated
that rule of thumb based on her research
and correct it from wrong other people
here that should be the number should be
30% of the revenue coming
in
so we're supposed to be making this you
know with as many God rails and safe and
and safe to the state as possible so $4
million dollar a year really isn't going
to cut
the the anticipated harm that's going be
caused to the community understood
that's just my comment I don't know if
anybody I I agree with the
chief sen yes so just to I just want to
be clear so what we're talking about is
page
28 eliminating the entirety of um line
through 30 and replacing it
with so the language is uh 10% shall be
allocated to the Substance Abuse
Prevention and Recovery Fund established
by RSA 318 f23 and I asked to lead the
or $25 million whichever is
less so again CH Dave I understand you
you want the the need for more money and
Nothing Stops the
the future legisl change it if if the
fund is being depleted and being overly
consumed no pun intended um then we can
allow we can change the section A lot
and change the allotment for but I think
on the initial blush in the house this
was the recommended language that made
it 1598 made it through the house with
this distribution of funds and I think
it'll it'll it'll it's a it's a
political compromise if you will what I
what I can tell you is when the original
1598 that went forward and when it got
kind of hung up in ways and means and
they changed it to this part of the
problem was is that no one from DHHS
came in advocating for the money being
allocated there so it was really hard to
justify the expenditure I believe it
would have been Justified but we need
someone if someone came in and provided
some testimony of how that money would
be used that would go a long way I think
and I believe Senator Lang was on the
Ways and Means Committee in the house
last term when I did testify and I was
asked that specific question where does
the number 25 million come from and
being brutally honest be kind of just
pulled it out of the sky so if if it can
be some specifics as to what that money
would be used for I think that can go a
long way and Senator Lang is I believe
chair of a way me committee
now I so I understand what you're saying
about the the prior legislation but the
result of last last the last legislative
session was for us to listen to We we've
had testimony here we we ourselves had
testimony with the need for that and
what it would be going towards we heard
from the doctors from Massachusetts we
heard from uh Dr Lyn silver so I think
we had the information here from very
credible sources that 30% is you know at
the
minimum to uh would be would be the
right way to
go any other
discussion
yeah
um I think a much of the conversation in
this commission has been about public
health and uh making sure that whatever
model that we do
um you know puts Public Health at top of
mind and so I would agree with what
you're saying about the this amount and
so I don't know if we
I
mean the recommendation of it being 10%
I think is a very fair start and then
you know should it go to finance which
it likely will maybe that's where they
want to place that limit that would be
my suggestion keep it at the 10% and if
that limit wants to be placed on at the
finance committee do
that this is no by no means final
language that and and you know I think
when it's in front of the the w means
Comm with the house or the Senate that's
the time to really fight this one out
but I agree I think the number you're
talking about these to
long so is the consensus to leave it at
10% 10% or $25 million je is less well I
think it's that latter Clause that we're
saying we don't need that that could
that could be done at
Finance is that what you're
saying he wants
30% yeah he wants 30% so I don't think
it's a 25 million or less that he's
fighting over I think it's the
compensation of the percentage in in and
of itself he's not happy with it so well
why don't we split that one second let
go to Frank and I'll come to you
Chim
um my only thought here is I mean I
agree in terms of having more money for
um for this um for this in this section
but just the flag if to keep the 25
million it just creates bad math at the
end so I would just pull that and then
we keep it even percentages that's fine
I'm not gonna die on that Hill okay so
leave it at 10% but but to the people
out there that want that number higher
when it's in front of the ways and means
commit
I'm the only one there we saw what
happened I was just sitting there and no
one showse showed up to ask for that or
Jud so at this this point we've adopted
we've agreed to adopt the um was the new
Futures language who was it well before
we do that Nami just um indicated that
they had language on this as well that
was emailed we we adopted earlier in the
day early in the bill some nami's
language about what it could be used for
uh there's a representative from Nami
today if they want to
hi Holly Stevens um from Nami New
Hampshire and we just had some language
in this section that would indicate that
50% of that 10% would be used for mental
health um mental illness treatment um
regardless of whether there's a
co-occurring uh substance use disorder
or not the reason for that is just so
that the governor's commission would be
aware that the money could well that 50%
of it would have to be used for mental
health and that in addition to that that
it wouldn't matter whether there was a
co-occurring um substance disorder or
not I did send that language to um some
folks this weekend as well as asking for
it to be sent to the full committee and
I do have hard copies with me so it just
adds one sent sent to that section so if
you have hard copies why pass out so we
can all look at it so the exact language
where it goes so are you okay with what
we've adopted so far about Tien that
language and then add a second sentence
to what one sentence that's added
yes I'd have no objection having another
percentage of the whole fund going to
mental health but now we're cutting if
we're mandating half the half the amount
of the projected 4 million we haven't
adopted yet we're just having a
conversation just I would I would Echo
his sentiments um that that would be
even worse and and maybe maybe we should
just right now decide to maybe make it
15% and make a little compromise there
you know he he suggesting 30 Dr Lyn
silver who gave us fantastic testimony
overall suggested that we put all these
guide rails in before we go further down
the road um and her testimony was
phenomenal but why not give him 15 %
instead of the
30 further I want to wait till is the
Nami is that coming
around I tell the first one the first
drafts on 1598 the first 25 million went
to them but then no one showed up to the
hearing to advocate for that on in
myself so that's where I would get to
this point so for the PE the advocacy to
get it
higher it's now in the
reverse when they're saying what passed
the house last
term that's what that's what passed the
original language was much much better
or what your excuse
me oh you see right there I just that
way sen L could I just add that I agree
with the gentleman um and Senator abis
you're mentioning that that DHS didn't
uh DHHS didn't attend or show you know
interest in that having that discussion
were they invited to provide testimony
on this topic because I'm not sure that
everybody sort of you know looks how
they can swoop in and okay well so I a
formal invitation wasn't sent but I'm
I'm confident they were DHS DHHS was
aware of the so let's not look backwards
again let's go forward okay um so I'll
make a compromise how about we drop I to
45% two two to 30% increase 3 to 20% oh
wait say that again so break it up so
it's the first section in three in the
breakdowns of funding so we're back into
the breakdowns so the first one will be
45% the second one will be 25% we reduce
5% from each one and then we'll add that
10% we just saved on the first two uh
distributions and add it to the mental
to the uh sub abuse program I would just
want to reduce it to 20% to hold on hold
on so we take we take a little bit from
each and and add it to the mental health
and substance is that is that
reasonable I prefer the lower the
property taxes if if you ask me I think
that's something that people are
throughout the state are having to deal
with so I think I don't I would want to
leave Roman num I as it is R num one so
you want 50 2020 50 20 yeah 50
no 2020 yeah we're talking about
now when we're when we're talking
about the 30% or whatever percentage
that was going to be taken from the
revenues to was supposed to be to
alleviate the harm that is caused by uh
legalization of marijuana uh cannabis
and
but now that we're saying we're going to
be funding mental health treatment that
has nothing to do with it we haven't had
a mental health language yet okay but I
don't want to come across as I'm I'm I
advocate I'm advocating for mental
health treatment uh I think if if if we
want to use funds we should give them
their own light item so to speak and
give them funds but I'm still talking
about the inadequacy of dealing with the
harm that's going to be happening from
the use of marij uh the increased use of
marijuana so I just want to that
clear I just also wanted to bring back
the attention to the committee about um
the harm that they know that it's linked
to first episode psychosis and we've
heard from Dr SED at New Hampshire
hospital as well as Lisa Madden at um
right here in in h
conquer that they are planning to see a
huge increase in um mental illness and
with the first episode cois if somebody
only smokes once and they end up with
that condition for the rest of their
life they may not have a
co-occurring substance use disorder
because they may never use again and so
that is why we think it's extremely
important for one you know for the
prevention of substance use disorders in
the first place we know that a lot of
folks who have depression anxiety and
psychosis end up using in order to
alleviate the symptoms um and we also
know that um it it causes certain now
now we know there's a correlation
between use and the uptick in mental
illness and that's the reason that we're
making that request because we think
it's so correlated that it's important
that half the money go to mental health
treatment all right so let's see if we
can Corral this into a into some sort of
vote for position so we can move on
Chief did you have something okay so
right now the discussion is 50220 is to
propose change to allow I will say that
as again I was on Ways and Means last
term and and the amendment that changed
these percentages with my amendment that
that set this up and again I did it
based on conversation who came in and
testified and who came in and for the
State of New Hampshire about how money
was going to be used and what was going
on and to to Senator abbas's Point
nobody showed up like even this we were
I was a little nervous about even this
language because we didn't have whether
or not um the agency was agreeing to it
even um and so um I I'm going to
recommend the 50 2020 I'd rather not
include the mental health provision I'd
rather you work with the with the
commission to figure out what the best
use of the funds that they have are for
whether mental health is that component
I wouldn't want to split it up to
another percentage mental health is is
INR uh that's for children
specifically so we have and remember we
do have a second line of 5% the very the
very next uh um bottom line number five
is a 5% distributed to dhh just for this
explicit purpose of mental health for
children I I need to add one more
wrinkle apologies we did also agree as a
group to add the Justice reinvestment
fund that was on the memo the new
Futures memo that you Senator abis can
ice see that langage page page three
number
10 so
I guess this will provide for people
impacted
from Impact so that language was
originally in HB
639 is that right did I get that
right so and that was important um to
both new futures of the public health um
agen or organization uh it was important
into other Justice focused groups that
were supporting legalization for the
purpose of making sure that we are
rebalancing uh that particular issue
about the impact of legalization on
communities of color um so that was a
tenant that was agreed to I think by I
don't know I don't know if so what
percentage where's this money coming
from well and that's the conversation
that's why right so now we're going to
strip down the percentages even more can
I can I ask so it says the f the fund
shall be used to support communities and
individuals impacted by poverty
unemployment and underemployment and
cannabis enforcement so this is just I I
understand what the I'm not saying these
are you not good causes but this is this
the timee we're dealing with this I mean
we have an analment section already
we've even expanded that what having now
a fund to do
it is
that I'm just what do we what are we
figure what are we trying to do here I
think the the thinking of this is beyond
the individuals who are impacted by past
criminal convictions it's kind of the
global impact of the war on drugs and
how it's been disproportionately felt by
certain communities uh certain
individuals and certain communities um
and it's an attempt to start to create
redress for that history um and so
because of underinvestment in those
communities um and over enforcement in
those communities having enfor I'm sorry
over enforcement well if you look at um
disparity rates in terms of Marijuana
arrest for example you know we know
black people and white people use
marijuana at roughly the same rate in
New Hampshire black people are over four
times more likely to be arrested than
white people looking at the most recent
202020 or 2022 2022 FBI UCR
data who are people getting arrested in
New Hampshire still for marijuana I I'm
not hearing about any according to the
FBI data sets it we at almost a thousand
people FBI FBI yes how many people were
arrested though uh almost a, 9960
something a thousand people were
arrested for using marij marijuana in
New Hampshire in 2022 when it's been
decriminalized is that are those being
prosecuted at the I'm just trying to get
hold up here what we're what we're
actually going to be
aling I'm not sure of the distribution
of those um those straight up arrest
wouldn't be prosecuted at the Attorney
General's office so I don't have
specific information yeah I mean I can
let's get control of the committee again
so Frank go ahead you respond to the AG
and then be um yes so this is just of
FBI UCR data portal for arrests in New
Hampshire 2020 20 2022 is the most
recent and it was late 960 arrests so I
don't know the outcome I don't know
quantity this is but this is only
possession not possession with intent or
distribution or things like that um and
so this fund was our you know an attempt
by a number of Advocates to set up some
type of process and some type of Revenue
stream that could go towards redress for
those historical injustices that have
happened here in in our
state sen Whitley yeah I just was hoping
that Kate from new Futures could come up
and speak to that issue as well because
it was in her Memo hold on um
representative hunt John yeah I'm
because I like to move things along um
the problem I'm having is is we're
debating numbers so we have no idea how
much money we're going to bring in so my
preference would be that we create these
funds because we think the public policy
that these funds should exist put in a
minimum dollar amount that we pretty
sure we will get within the first three
years or whatever this thing is and then
knowing full well that things change and
three years from now we're where the
best place to be putting money it might
be different than what we think of today
and let the ways and means committees in
the future years then decide to put more
money in the funds that are most
appropriate but that that just get
create the funds put some minimal amount
of money into each one of them and then
let let the process play itself
out
Chief these numbers that you're reciting
are from State Police numbers being
entered into
UCR that are actual short summonses for
violations these are not arrest these
are part of the decriminalization
process that's we've gone through so
it's not arrest okay it's it's enfor
of what we're supposed to be doing it's
not we're picking on individuals we're
enforcing the laws as they're currently
written Su I just want to add that the
it looks like the categories that that
are already listed here are are known
concrete tangible things to put money
towards and when you start working off
of a social justice framework it ends up
being something with good intent but a
total bul doogle at every turn and so I
I would recommend just keeping it with
the the actual concrete things that
people can see on a tangible level like
Retirement Systems education substance
abuse treatment
Etc further comment senator be Whitley
yeah I think the social justice
framework is incredibly important I
don't think it's a boond dog all I think
many many many people support
legalization for the very one of the
critical points about why they support
it is because of the unequal enforcement
of drug laws and so I don't think it's a
boond dog I think it's very very
critical piece of this discussion I
would be supportive of what
representative hunt suggested about
creating the funds and then letting the
various policy Finance committees
determine the percentages so I would
advocate for adding this Justice
reinvestment fund and then you know the
creation of the fund and let you know
punt on the issue I would add that if
people care about social justice in this
and if this is a priority for them it's
really in a lot of ways many people have
been in some ways um the numbers get
inflated where you're talking about
arrest and and chief is correcting it
saying this not it's just part of the
process so if if any of this the social
justice aspect of this gets say people
are really uh wanting this language in
there um I would I would counter to say
they've been there's been a lot of Mal
education on the social justice aspect
Frank I would I guess just push back
they're not inflated that's literally
just if you go to the FBI UCR data
portal that's what it says I'm just
providing that information to the
committee but there's not even a
definition of people of color so all
right so so let's let's re it back in so
the the question is do we want to
establish fund John's repr hunts
recommended we establish fund I tend to
disagree with this concept and the only
reason it being is it's a bigger broader
larger conversation than just this one
topic of marijuana um we have programs
already to deal with poverty we have
programs already to deal with
underemployment we have programs already
to deal with all these things within the
state and going to carve out a little
more money and stick it somewhere that
doesn't make a unified program
accessible or given directed towards
this so I don't think this is the place
to have this kind of conversation myself
I think that someone wants to bring a
bill in to do this have at it and you
know come to my fees and funds committee
over in ways and means I'll be happy to
have that discussion um but I'm not sure
that this is the right Bill to start
having a social discussion which is what
this is a social discussion
um it's not it's not an enforcement
discussion it's not a legalization
discussion it's about social social
policy which and I don't think it
belongs in this bill my personal belief
so all those in favor of adding this
fund into the bill raise your
hand all those opposed raise your hand
we're going to strike that language and
you're welcome to do an addendum to the
committee to bring that language in
thank you for
that um moving on so we're all set with
the I'm sorry do we finalize 50 2020 we
are all all those in favor of 50220
raise your
hand all those opposed to 50
20255 so the eyes have it we'll leave it
we'll change the breakdown to 50 20 2055
for the dispersement of
funds um moving on to 20 section 23 can
I can I just discuss some number two
real
quick disperse to um the Retirement
Systems unfunded AC crude
liabilities this is a co- mangling of
funds if you put marijuana money into
the retirement system that will
jeopardize the entire retirement system
all of the money in there so the entire
bill is is a comingling of funds we have
one is education trust fund we're
dumping marijuana money into education I
understand that so but it jeopardizes is
all current and former state employees
local
employees as far as their retirement
system so I think we heard from the
treasur the state treasurer who said
that they could this could be
done without without that risk all right
moving on we're at section 23 the
Substance Abuse Prevention and Recovery
Fund um any conversation here Becca you
were again you were in charge during
this so I'm not sure want to make sure
that
everything we didn't
have right so this was the consensus
that we should create a separate non-aps
fund correct
Chief so how about we add uh there's
hereby established in the State Treasury
the
non-aps right well make here it says
non-lps in
MH Subs abuse treatment uh prevention
treatment and Recovery Fund yep yep did
we change your name of that we did yeah
just it's it's uh we did it all through
the bill earlier it's substance abuse uh
prevention treatment and
Recovery uh that be distinct and
separate from all other funds
yep so again the the 20% that we is
what's going to go into that
f um TW page 29 that looks like we had
um uh no changes according to my notes
the line out the strikeouts you do were
from the original Bill
strikeout uh going to page
30 would you strike out no no we didn't
strike anything else we just said the
strikeouts are already in there were
from a previous strikeout cor that
wasn't based on us
um well Becky you had a conversation
around the definition of marijuana it
looks like yeah we got rid we got rid of
the
definition right and we we were just
going to add a reference because there
was conversation about we use cannabis
and
marijuana so the idea being just say Mar
uh subject marijuana includes the
definition of cannabis products
for no we were going to use instead of
the definition for marijuana we were
going to use the definition that we
already created for
cannabis let me go back
to what page is that on we're on page
30 and I apologize interrupting my on my
computer the line number is no longer
match PR C so I I
think instead of you you want to do a
cut and I not have the definition
reference have two different definitions
defined I think it's smarter to say
marijuana and do just a reference to uh
318 F1 Roman numeral 2 yeah me just say
marijuana
means the definition of cannabis as
defined in does that make
sense well we were going to eliminate
the definition of marijuana Al together
well I think the problem we have is it's
referenced in other parts of the statute
no it's not because that's that's that's
this is the this is the area that we're
talking about so I think so 318 B2 is
the beginning of the B right right
that's in the definition section yeah so
we want the controlled Drug Act to
Define marijuana as the definition we're
using in we're using 318
F what we're trying to do is is use
consistent language across all of our
statutes so we're switching all of the
references to marijuana and current law
to our current new def of cannabis so
just so so again so the recommendation I
think if I'm reading this right it will
say instead of this big long from 14 to
20 we have in here now um the statute
will say Mar uh for the purpose of
section marijuana will be defined as in
RSA what is the 318
F1 yeah Roman numeral 2 we got to change
it does that make sense everybody we're
going to use go back to the original
definition of just cannabis say Mar
marijuana equals the definition of
cannabis which is on 318 F1 Roman
numeral
2 you got that
darl number one number
two all
right moving on to
31 this is
again but if we reference to Dam
definition it doesn't
matter do matter we need or we just need
to
say I want to change that's going to be
repealed all right so nothing on 31
going on to
32 oh last we take that up
yeah
um
so
what's that
say I'm sure be free upon request by the
defendant and by so here we're talking
about the analment of certain crimes or
convictions of cannabis and this is
where the Frank has some language
somewhere see all should have somewhere
was handed out
um this this sheet that looks like this
and talks about the enement process
Frank why don't you walk us through this
real quick definitely so uh
um the first part is just definitions um
section the second part has to do with
um arrests and convictions um it
includes a process to challenge
particularly in the context of
distribution uh to youth if the past
conviction had to do with that um and
giving uh prosecutors in the court the
ability to not Grant the um the analment
if that if those facts are in relevant
in this in the individual
case um the next section is just an
automatic enement for and this is just
misdemeanor and violation level offenses
for
marijuana um third section you can just
strike because this is resentencing and
I know we talked about not doing
resentencing in this
bill um and then the fourth section is
the what we had talked about in our
earlier conversation around uh pending
marijana want cases and just the
dismissal process and so this was uh the
product of a number of folks uh working
on a standalone Bill and so we thought
this might be more appropriate to try
and incorporate in here um and also to
kind of work through the way the current
courts uh
operates so again I'm only looking at
the first page and the top of the second
page right now
um of the back of the page um yeah sorry
for my printing that's okay so we're
talking about basically anybody who's
been convicted of a crime that's now
going to be legal um is eligible to
submit a petition to the court for an
analment of the previous
conviction um and that law enforcement
that upon a receiving that petition the
court will notify the prosecutor the
prosecutor then have a a right to object
um based on the grounds that are in here
um the you know the offense is not
eligible for annulment um
that kind of thing and then um absent
that it'll automatically be
granted I think that that does create a
legal problem so that means the Court's
going to be required to go around and
find every single possession conviction
that's happened and then they they're
required to then basically anull that
which I I understand some people may
feel that that condition was an injust
in the first place but I'm just saying
it's every single one and I'm not even
sure the court has a mechanism finding
pulling them up that way now if someone
applies for an analment well this is an
application process right yeah this is
an application process it has an
application yeah so again it says any
person who was arrested or convicted May
at any time petition the court yeah so
again this isn't a a universal wipe this
is the person who is subject to the
criminal offense has to request um the
analment and then upon upon request of
the annulment the court will begin the
process which is to notify the
underlying arresting uh Authority let
them object if they choose to and if
they don't object in a timely fashion
then it's presumed to be allowed to be
analled and the court will just anull it
at that point and if the if the law
enforcement does object there'll be a
hearing and the and the law enforcement
present its evidence to why it should
not be a
known Chief do you have a comment on
that you you good I have no comment okay
and do you mind emailing
that so are we okay with that Dave just
just out of curiosity uh it outlines
what would be it seems like to outline
what would be grounds for an objection
to be made but I see nothing if somebody
has had a subsequent and steady uh
criminal record it doesn't allow the
prosecutor it seems by reading this
doesn't allow the prosecutor to say say
well this part of getting an analment is
that you you haven't committed any
crimes since
then our thinking here is that it's no
it's it's no longer illegal and so the
presumption should be in favor of
clearing the record um and so if there's
other criminal things happening
obviously those that record would
maintain um this is just with regard to
something that is no longer legal so
that's we thought was an appropriate
balance
there
further conversation about the inment
process again I'm only going number five
all fees where at the last section just
a quick question for Frank um why two
ounces is that
a on the first page on right at near the
beginning you had two ounces one at
three one at one oh sorry I think I was
thinking that was the amount we were
going to so that would just be tweaked
to it reflect whatever the legalization
limit is okay again earlier we we we
recommended four as the number so this
number should go to four right if you
have four ounces or less and you're
convicted of a
um because it's now
legal so is there any objection to
includes let me do a switch all those in
favor of of using this um language as
presented up to number five this as far
as we're we're talking about that for
right now so want to talk to Frank about
the rest of it um who's in favor of
including this analment language
Frank so who's opposed to including this
anman
language all right so we're not going to
include so we're back to the existing
language that's in
there um my recommendation is again this
is another thing that we it's been
debated and I think the conversations
are healthy but when you have a very
complex uh policy Bill like this that
we're putting forward perhaps the
analment section is one that we we
revisit separately and not let let this
be part of the stalling process Mr chair
you mean like like representative hunt
suggested making a study committee for
an nment I'm not sure this one needs as
much studying but
yes or punting might be the other term
that's been thrown around it just we
don't we don't agree on which one to go
with but this is this is not really
related to this state run franchise
model and that for that reason I think
we can I would take the analment section
out not saying that they shouldn't be I
mean I think having consistency there is
we we should do that but do we do it in
this bill I would say
no so is your recommendation um Senator
abis that we strike the entire section
the number 15 on P starting at the
bottom of page 31 new section sentences
annulment of certain arrest in Comm I we
strike all of that yeah and then that's
not again that's not a criticism to the
policy it's just maybe that's better off
as a standalone I know Senator again you
have a bill on the nanograms for driving
it's a separate bill altoe and I think
you look it it will go through the
policy changes okay M um I think we
would object to that I think for a lot
of the reasons that we talked about with
regard to the investment the social
justice investment fund um because
there's a legacy of discriminatory
enforcement in New Hampshire I think is
one aspect and also just the Practical
reality that I think part of what we're
trying to do is remove hurdles
unnecessary hurdles to people being able
to succeed in their communities and we
know from substantial research that both
access to housing and access to
employment are key um U markers of
successful ways to reduce recidivism we
also know that having a marijuana
conviction on your record makes it more
difficult to both get housing and to get
employment um so I think you know our
from our perspective if we're really
focused on public safety and and
creating a harm reduction prior um bill
then ensuring that we have a clean
process for annulments is is key to that
but we have that for three quarters
announc us
right do we want to change that now or
not represent sen Whitley sorry yeah I I
would be opposed to taking this section
out I think also we are now making some
uh you know we're this is this is making
something legal and so it's a
fundamental unfairness about not
addressing this issue about you know
people that were arrested for net
conduct that will not be legal I think
if we don't address this I think that's
a huge gap that's a punt that I'm not
willing to participate in all right so
any other new comments sure so the only
thing I'll say is again I think that
nothing prohibits anybody from refiling
already for an enement once if this was
to become law they could file for an
analment so nothing prohibits them so
we're not prohibiting any activity by a
person already convicted the only
process only thing we're saying is that
there's not going to be an automated
process for um an could could we just
change the existing Anan law and it says
34s anounce could we just change that to
say whatever the number we come up with
Ian why are we having this whole new
section well the question is we're going
to take it out now and leave it for
someone to file a bill which again we
have 30 months before this is
potentially going happen so anybody
after anybody could file for an enement
anyway as it exists so I I was just
about to off I says what let's just not
reinvent the wheel because we know
nothing's going to happen for three
years so let's if if we all we have to
do is take the current law and put in
what this bill this looks like when
we're here and then to to refine it to
make it better that absolutely is is
best to be handled through a separate
legislation so let's let's take a a
quick vote and see where we are rather
than keep having a a circular discussion
um all those in favor of
striking um at the bottom of 31 new
section sentences annulment and certain
arrests and convictions for cannabis
striking that entire section all the way
to the page 32 line 26 which are all the
provisions of that all those in favor of
striking that language and letting it
dealt with somewhere else raise your
hand so that's the majority of the
committee so we're going to strike that
language and then
again and again this if this if this
legislation filed that this whatever
this Comm commission recommends they can
be an amendment to that bill when it's
fired fired
filed to address the analment section so
again we don't have the conversation on
over but I think for our recommendation
we're just punting one do that does that
make
sense again doesn't stop anybody who
currently has conviction on their record
if this law was a pass to file a
petition and do it anyway and the court
may or may not Grant it all right moving
on uh assessment education tax all this
says is that the standard uh State
assessment of tax for Education trust
fund for the Statewide education
property tax is $363 million annually um
and this says that going forward it will
be $363 million less the appropriation
that we made of the funds in the uh in
the in the revenue stream
that number that number is still correct
that's all correct that's still correct
so any there was no changes recommended
there um use of the cannabis for
therapeutic
purposes so sections 17 through 24 is
all just to clarify is all language that
was added to make sure that op that atcs
have the opportunity to convert to for
profit status okay so sections 17
through 24 so 17 through 24 all the
language were just added to allow atcs
to move from a not for-profit status to
a for-profit status any objection in
that
language I thought we were going to
allow them to sorry file for a
franchise right but in order to be to to
have their same company now be a
franchise right because we have an LLC
underneath that they need to be go moved
to a for-profit model and so that's what
this allows for is them to be able to do
that correct because otherwise they
wouldn't be able to participate in
detail all right so so um moving on to
section 25 liquor investigation training
um there looks like there was no
discussion around any changes
there moving on to the
36 it doesn't look like there was any
language
there um it looks like this is new
language at the bottom for appropriation
for department of safety for the purpose
of generating that report that uh we
asked for earlier in the
bill yep and then we appropriate some
money to liquor um out of the current
budget for uh purposes of Ru making and
all the stuff they have to do that we're
asking them to
do do we know where in the bill because
I have I I can't find it where in the
bill we were keeping track of the
fatalities in CarX do we was that report
that the report requirement let me see
if I can find it was back here was the
one represent H was asking
about all right I'm G have to find it
for you you know I just wanted to make
sure that that stat was included that's
what that this is the money for them to
generate that
report and then money for liquor to be
able to do the startup um before they
have Revenue coming
in all right any so that's the language
of the bill we have one major topic to
discuss and that's the creation of the
advisory commission for uh cannabis
advisory commission
um what's
that
miss the last one I
think
items take up um the first we're going
to we're going to take up is the
advisory the Cannabis advisory
commission um and we need to talk about
um that is you know all the conditions
of that commission who is attached to
which is obviously liquor the makeup of
that committee who we want on that
committee and some of the basic roles
responsibilities and functions of that
committee where is that going to go it's
going to be a whole new section somewh I
don't know where but it's going to be a
whole so this is I think this is a place
to start this is the the starting kind
of language um um so we're creating a c
whatever we want to call it but cannabis
Public Health advisory commit uh
committee convened by The Liquor
Commission charged with making
recommendations on public health issues
such as or M making issues including but
not limited to THC potency limits for
cannabis products and serving sizes
packaging labeling marketing and
advertising standards to prevent
targeting to minors this advisory
committee is not intended to make
recommendations on cannabis business
related issues so again so again the one
I was asked to remind everybody to turn
their mics on when they SP speak because
there's people listening in in the
digital world that can't hear us when
we're talking um so let's start with a
simple roles of responsibilities so what
is going to be the primary um
responsibility I think it's not just
Public Health I think it's the overall
operations of the Cannabis retail model
whether it's relevant to Public Health
whether it's relative to law enforcement
whether it's relative to enforcement
mechanisms um packaging and labeling I
think it's a a little bit bigger myself
um I I just don't want to limit it to
Public Health because there could be a
very narrow definition of Public Health
and I don't know that we want we want
them to be advising the commission on
how to manage this new function that
we're doing my opinion up to comments
for oh is that does that sound
so their their role will be Public
Health right and I think in within that
maybe there's a subsection and that when
when we are saying Public Health we are
saying we want I I want to include all
these things so we can Define Public
Health what that is well not de not
decline not Define Public Health but
include within that bucket what we want
them to look at so look at Public Health
public health component there a law
enforcement enforcement component or
I'll just say enforcement regulatory so
you guys uh I appreciate the efficiency
you're working with but you guys
mind I'll give it to you when I write it
up I'll write it up for you and give it
to you once I'm done and you can just
patch where you
want we're not saying where in the bill
it's going to go but um all right so we
have uh we have and then we have three
the the business operations component so
this is the charge of the commission
yep so three main charges Public Health
enforcement
regulatory um advis you know opinions
and then uh business operative
operations uh as well is there anything
else for big big buckets that we can we
can define those a little bit better but
ough for big buckets does that sound
like we what we want this advisory
commission to be talking about
soon all right so given those big
buckets which we'll talk about uh Public
Health enforcement Regulatory and then
business operations they'll discuss
those things in the advisory commission
to make recommendations on this new
model um what what they and ongoing
they'll make recommendations so my
recommendation is this is an ongoing
commission this isn't just a startup
commission so this is once they'll meet
minimum once a year right at a minimum
right just to make sure that or as
necessary um and they'll they'll deal
with the
ongoing science is going to change
business opportunities going to change
there be lots of enforcement may change
um and allow them to meet regularly so
they'll meet annually at at minimally
once a
year you have to write that in there yes
because I found out I was on a
commission on the chair and I never
called a meeting CU I didn't know I was
on it so uh I never got the notice so I
think that by calling out that they're
responsible and well when we break it
out um my recommendation is we identify
whoever the person is probably at the
the liquor enforcement the liquor uh
representative will be responsible of
calling the meeting when necessary at
least once a year and that way we know
who's responsible regardless of who the
chairman may be we have one person
designated to call a meeting and make
sure there's a meeting called all right
um who do you want on
it Chief I would recommend a
representative from the New Hampshire
Liquor
Commission a law enforcement rep
appointed by the New Hampshire
Association of chiefs of police a public
health rep a representative from the
medical you're typing faster than I can
I can write I know he's way behind me
but all right by the New Hampshire
Chiefs Association who was your third
person Public Health
rep uh on that maybe a representative
from like the New Hampshire Department
of Health and Human Services Public
Health Division and also maybe new
Futures as the public health well I have
advocacy agcy get finished so I have the
medical community in addition to Public
Health and then a representative from
new
Futures when you say Public Health do
you mean from Department of Health and
Human Services no Public Health it could
be a any within that variety around
appointed
byed by whom the governor it could sorry
and then you had somebody Pro say have
Public Health Medical what was the next
new Futures new
Futures
say
yeah yeah I'd like to see uh someone
from Sam smart approaches to marijuana
um and someone from
caddy so we'll put
um we have a representative of the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission as appointed
by the commissioner of of of lior
uh we have a law enforcement person as
uh appointed by the Chiefs Association
we have a public health official we
haven't identified with that was we have
a medical person and I'm going to say
that's by the New Hampshire Medical
Society can I can I make the suggestion
that maybe it's the same makeup as this
commission plus an ADV a little bit
unwielding yeah with the number of us
that are here that that are in different
position my thought is you're going to
be trying to develop rules regulations
policies and and all this other stuff
and this many people not working out now
so I'm I hope we can keep it to nine I'm
hoping we can keep it no more than nine
people there's a reasonable number we're
already up to five Dave perhaps somebody
from um
education due to the fact uh they'll
they'll know whether or not what's going
on in the
schools so want to point the of the uh
Commissioner of Education the
Hampshire
and I'm going to I'm going to recommend
we have at least one Senator and one
representative on it because if there's
legislative changes that come out that
aren't rules or anything else you need
someone to be act as a as a champion for
those to move them
forward so seven and eight we have one
more position if we keep it to nine we
have a senator and a rep sorry to
potentially throw a wrench Just one
thought is you know I think kind of the
the global or the the broad um mandate
that I think it sounds like we're trying
to put on this group maybe a little bit
too broad I think you know liquor has
expertise in enforcement already liquor
has expertise in the business side but
where there is like where I think um and
I think new fatures original
recommendation came from was a
recognition that on the public health
side of this and how marijuana and
public health intersect and how to
create good policy was a place where
there was potentially a gap and so the
need to create um a new kind of discreet
advisory body to fill that Gap um and so
I guess a concern is that like we're
creating too broad of a entity without a
clear mandate when we when there's
already expertise in two of the three
areas within liquor um and so my
suggestion would be like I I like what
new features had put together and so my
suggestion would be whether it'd be
worth trying to kind of narrow in and
focus on that original mandate so I I I
would tend to disagree because the argu
argument we're going to have is okay
Public Health let's talk about that does
that include the
labeling I right but does that include
labeling does that how would that deal
with you know one of the things we
talked about here is suspension of lure
and stuff like that if there's an
injustice happening within liquor who's
going to be the advisory panel to bring
that up to liquor and say this is not
being enforced evenly or anything else
if there's a complaint right the whole
point of this commission this this
advisory commission is the we need to
advise you on all aspects of what you're
doing and how that would work um because
it's a brand new brand new topic and a
brand new um business model and so what
is that who's we have so to do that
because it is such a big thing we have
public health we have enforcement we've
got things about education um to do that
um so this this commission
just I think before you start appointing
members to it you want to figure out
what's before we start naming who's on
the commission we really want to narrow
the scope what the charge of the
commission is and from that point it you
you I think you can what Senator Whitley
said use kind of what we have now this
but you can cut down some of the refs in
Senators right there's only one of each
I think by doing that to the CH point
this is a large commission we've been
kind of banging heads but if you kind of
limit this corner over here I think it
will work right sen whitle yeah I would
agree that because a lot of the our work
you know around the state control model
was to focus on public health that's why
I think if we have a an advisory
committee focused on public health you
know that way you know we we can be the
leader on this issue which is the whole
intention behind the state control model
that we are the leaders on the public
health side I think there's so much to
look at on the public health side all
all of which you know we can Define you
know like labeling um you know this
public awareness campaign um potency
levels there's just so much on the
public health side that needs
continuing you know A continuing look at
because of the science changes I think
it becomes too unwieldy if you have you
know this again I don't I don't think
that's necessary that's why I said nine
we limited to nine which is a reasonable
committee it's not unwieldy in terms of
the number of people it's unwieldy in
terms of the number of issues that's why
I think the most important thing that we
need advice on is public health because
changes so much and because we know we
have heard the impact you know that
legalization will have because there's
science involved that's what we really
need the advice on so as I'm laying this
out right now four of the nine um
appointees are all in the public health
sphere right and then you have two
legislators and then you've got liquor
right who just talk about how it's GNA
how how it works and have that input
into the committee to be able to be a
member of the committee to be able to
speak about how operations work how
things look what the current rules and
regulations are to be able to speak
authoritatively when it meets and you
have one law enfor only one law
enforcement person on it to talk about
how uh that's being managed and dealt
with you know what is the you say public
health and I'd argue okay fine so DUI is
that a public health issue public
consumption is that a public health
issue right but that's an Enforcement
issue to me but it's also a public
health issue and so why shouldn't we
have a cop on there what about the
Attorney General's office have to give
you well that's job my good
for so
so you know we had this conversation
actually in a previous a previous
meeting and we decided we don't want to
be overly intrusive in terms of what the
Liquor Commission is going to do they
are going to be The Regulators they are
going to be the one that is responsible
for doing a whole heck of a lot in
implementation of this model so we don't
want to over legislate in terms of
telling them what to do they are
responsible and we are delegated that
authority to them but they are not the
public out and I don't think they would
claim to be and so the sort of middle of
the
ground uh solution was to just create
this public health advisory committee I
think um and it I don't know if the
Liquor Commission wants to speak to that
too that sort of that sort of balance of
over regulate or over being overly
prescriptive yet also wanting to provide
the support that you may need on the
public health
side senator I would agree with you that
the public health side is the side of
the business that uh we are uh less
inclined to have knowledge of so we want
to make sure that we can run the
business and run it uh efficiently and
profitably and my idea of this committee
would be uh someone to call we call
these meetings we have ideas we have
concerns or someone that's on the
committee has ideas and concerns and the
public health piece would be the most
most important piece for us we
agree and so again so the question is
like but where where would public
consumption fall into that is that a
public health piece do you think we
should have law enforcement involved in
that
discussion right and so that's why
they're member I I'm putting them down
as a member of the committee right
because it is a public health issue mean
right how is enforcement happening in in
in the law again they're advising on how
this model is working then they need to
make recom do they need to make
recommendations for legislation that's
why I'm think you need one Senator and
one House member is to be able to bring
forward things that are Beyond rules but
need to be addressed or piece of the law
that needs to be changed because liquor
is operating under a model because
that's what they interpret the law to
read and so you need legislators on
there so I mean the only
person now we have again a public health
official which we haven't defined right
what that is who that is exactly a New
Hampshire Medical Society bring in
science we've got new Futures to bring
in public policy um arguments we have
have uh the uh at app Point D of
Department of Education to deal with how
it's impacting Youth and what's going on
in our schools as this new policy does
then we have a senator state
representative and I'm going to
recommend for the ninth person one
lensey someone who's licensed to be able
to come in to talk about how it actually
works um we may have a perception how it
works but having a ly on there may give
us insight into public policy and how
implementation might work but that's
just me
Tim I mean why why does it need to be a
representative from new fure futes we we
hear a lot from them all over the state
already why don't we bring in some new
blood and get fresh ideas that that
might work well and I'm okay just saying
public member appointed by the governor
and leaving it the governor can pick a
public a person who is representative
for them to bring in and not specify new
Futures specifically um and just say one
public member appointed by the
governor and they bring a general it
could be a private citizen that comes in
and has concerns or impact or could be a
policy wonk that the governor think
thinks is important to be heard from
so is there a department of a component
to this in any way with obviously when
you start getting into testing a product
and things like that if if these
products are to be grown in New
Hampshire does that involve is that
under some perview of Department of AG
in any way or so right now testing is as
we we're talking about a relative to a
third party testing at this point as as
administered by The Liquor
Commission Chief Senator I I have to
disagree with you about a member of the
people selling
it you wouldn't bring someone producing
tobacco in an oversight committee for
tobacco I'm okay with that I think I
think there's got to be a separation
there a conflict there
sure right you could bring them in and
ask them for input
but just so I'll strike that one I'll
just say one member of the public
appointed by the government it it does
need to be a balance though because what
looks good on paper doesn't always work
in the real world all right and what one
of the things I I've been critical of
some of the rules that exist now on
paper they're they look Rock Solid but
when it comes to enforcing that rule and
how does that rule impact the
franchisees I mean again they make a
recommendation legisl going to pass that
and adopt that that's a different story
I think it's important to make sure you
have every angle you're cover you want
you want the Chiefs on there you want
law enforcement on there to make sure
hey we can enforce this rule we can
enforce that law we can enforce that
policy right realistically speaking
right same thing will that policy even
will that imp how will that impact the
franchisees is that something that they
they think will be too
burdensome you know they're going to be
they're sitting in the room anyway the
whole time they'll be testifying whether
they're on the commission or I don't
it's ch their input but I I think it's
important to have everyone
involved if I could if I could ask
wouldn't that be covered under the Lial
commission though wouldn't since aren't
they representing in some ways as the
main franchiser wouldn't they be
representing those logistical
issues again I'm I'm okay with taking
off the person from the LIC I just added
CU I had ninth slot and I was trying to
figure who I who was a good I have an
idea and I'm okay with recommending just
a member of the public as appointed by
the governor and just leave at that so
it could be just a regular old taxpayer
if Governor thinks we need a policy wonk
he can appoint a policy wonk two
hospitals so two members of the
house now we 10 so that means we got to
go to 11 so we don't have
time um yes sen Whitley I just I'm a
little nervous we don't have enough
Public Health on there so we need a
certified public health
specialist so we have what again what we
really need advice on is potency limit
these pain labeling this is like the
nitty-gritty thing so we need that
expertise on there right so certified
public health all right
so did you have somebody on there from
prevention I just actually so I I
crossed out the public health official I
said the public health official has
appointed by the chairman of your
commission the commission on treatment
prevention substance yeah so you'll have
one member from your commission on that
on there as well as a pointed by may not
from your commission you may choose to
pick somebody else but it's appointed by
the chairman of your commission so one
other group I think that we have
included which we've heard a lot about
is mental health and so potentially Nami
or a group like Nami to make sure that
we have that angle
covered all
right hampire Medical Society okay um
I will say with this commission um I
think we're pretty close on it but
there's some things that we need we need
to get to I
think so I still need a definition of
what is a public health person and who's
the appointing authority certified
public health specialist That's like a
an
actual you know of course we want
someone certified in that area the
certified public health specialist
appointed
by DHHS
DHHS Public Health certified public
health specialist appointed by
DHHS and then I'm okay because we have
one more slot I got to fill because now
we're at 10 we can't have an even number
um and so we can do the 11th member
could be the commissioner Department of
Health need Services order designate
does that work for oh DHHS DHHS right
that make sense to
everybody so chairman I just want for
the record to make sure this is is an
advisory it is an advisory committee its
goal is to take topics and make
recommendations to The Liquor Commission
for either regulatory or legislative
changes so a couple other issues we have
to address this is this is on the same
topic no let's finish up this and then
before we move on I don't want we still
how much because the commission's taken
up a lot of time but that's that's
important piece for some people so are
we okay with this commission to break up
11 people the members are the
commissioner of I mean uh someone
appointed by the director of Malik
himself or design someone appointed by
the chief's Association a public health
official as appointed by the chairman of
the governor's Commission on um
prevention treatment and Rehabilitation
uh a medical person appointed by the New
Hampshire Medical Society a certified
public health um specialist what is it
certified public health specialist
specialist as appointed by DHHS
uh the Department of
Education uh commissioner or is Design
One Senator two house members one member
of the public appointed by the governor
and the commission of DHHS or their
designate those are the 11 members
making up the commission they have three
big policy topics Public Health
enforcement Regulatory and business
operations to advise the commission
on that good and we'll write all the
filler language around it great now we
can move on to another topic I have on
the list um there was one piece that
should be without objection you all I
don't know if you remember we had this
piece that talked about distribution and
warehousing um and we all approved it
but it never made it actually into the
bill so I'll give that to Daryl let just
get that to include it adds a new
definition for a cannabis distributor
and we want to make sure that gets into
the bill as well we we had missed it on
the other thing no that's that's key but
these on before people start taken off
uh there's a
couple we'll call them deal breakers
that need to be addressed so I think we
want to get to those soon as we can yep
one of them being the issue of the
amount of stores yeah that's next on my
list number of stores Dave I think you
had a comment on that
yeah about the top of my head the way
it's currently written it it references
the no more than the amount of liquor
stores or something to that effect but
what I from the governor's office what
we would recommend would be uh no more
than 15 stores and at sometime in the
future after this thing gets up and
running if then more could either be
added or deleted just to see in relation
to how things progress how they worked
well it didn't work Mr Mica you have a
comment on that limitation of cap on
stores at least to start off with and
then legislative change to grow beyond
that so they want to cap it at 15 stores
Statewide
I guess my only question would be how do
the atc's fit into the 15
stores so if an ATC were to apply be to
for retail be to be a franchisee and if
they were you know if they were selected
as the franchisee that would be one of
the
stores so they would have to apply for
one of the 15 licenses yes that's fine
again ATC would have the option working
in both mod working in one or the other
model so it could be a retail store sell
its therapeutic product in the retail
store and be a be governed by DHHS or it
could just stay a therapeutic store
which case it's governed by DHHS if it
just stays as a therapeutic store we
think that's a great number to start
with thank you so you're okay with
15 and before everyone just loses it I
can I can I can see some of the people
with the great poker
faces listen this is a starting point
it's it's not it could always a future
legisl could always address it but the
idea of compromise here and getting this
the Finish Line that's that's the best
number we
can you make it 20 it's not going to
work Jim I see a flaw with this you know
we came to compromise and work with you
guys in good faith that we would never
exceed the number of liquor stores that
language allows for exceeding the number
of liquor stores no it's not the
opposite no it's just the opposite it's
of the just 15 stores period just 15
stores not 65 but you're saying another
legislative body in the future could
raise that number if it it needs to have
the limit back and forth so you want to
leave that liit so hold on hold on John
so darl well but even as it was written
before the future legisl could still
change
it that that applies to every law other
than anything it's in the Constitution
John I agree I I mean in terms of 15
just you cannot b a future leg
okay to put it in say if it don't exceed
64 it makes it sound like we're we're
okay that to raise the number and then
beg the question well how you do that
well the only way you can do it is
through
legislation so don't sweat it the number
15 15 I can I can tell you from the
governor's office point of view that you
know we're at a minute about that number
15 can I just say we don't want to see a
proliferation of what's happening in
other states okay Becky I just I I have
a global sort of concern here is that we
just spent many many many many many many
many many months going through a 37 page
document many people have to leave I
have to leave at two and we are now
going to take up a list of issues raised
by the governor's office last night I I
feel like this is two issues most
already actually been addressed there
only two issues as far as I know this is
the one of the two there's a number of
stores a concern it just feels oh just
to to finish it feels very R rushed and
a little inefficient to have spent
months and months on this language the
various issues and then the very last
meeting the very last half hour to raise
these you know pretty substantial issues
we're not going to take any public
testimony on this limitation I'm not
saying I I support it or I don't support
it but we took all this public testimony
on these issues and we're going to raise
these issues at the very end without any
public input I just I see that
procedurally as problematic particularly
because this is the legislative body
so I can tell you to Governor all
conversations have been added about this
I I have brought it up uh I don't think
it's wise to leave the legislation that
cannot exceed the number of liquor
stores which would result in a
proliferation of pot shops all over the
state I think uh this is something that
we we got to move slowly on we want to
make sure that safety of the citizenry
is uh is taken care care of and as you
said perhaps in the future when
legislature could always uh change that
but at this this point we're adamant
about that number Mike do we have a a
cap in law for
atcs loc so maximum of eight
locations so it's not new territory
we're breaking new ground we're breaking
it's already been the model we're using
with therapeutic uh now we just the
question is do we expand into retail to
allow for um more stores than we do for
the therapeutic which is only eight
so
um they have have some issues with some
of the definitions just how the
therapeutic program would blend in but
we can do that we have one other
um policy issue let let's stick with the
15 let's stick with the 15 stores and
let's get that get that topic to who
who's in favor of amending the bill to
allow for up to no more than 15
stores okay so that's the majority of
the committee so darl we draft that
language and again you'll need to insert
it wherever we have the language
currently for I inserted it and we'll
cap the number of stores of 15 it's
under you want to speak
3-f does he want to come to the mic when
you come to the microphone so again so
people from this does not affect the
and there seven locations right I
understand my question this is my
question for you guys right you had 65
stores or whatever it was now we're down
to 15 you've projected uh the take for
the Liquor Commission to do this I can
tell you from someone that has a whole
bunch of stores that you aren't going to
collect the tax that you're projecting
near in 15 stores it's not even possible
so you're setting up the Liquor
Commission potentially to fail by by
limiting the number of stores that they
start out with how many stores you think
we we would need 50 cuz we were 100 in
Maine we're about the same size and it's
been retracting right and we're down to
about 80 but it's still not a healthy uh
situation for the for the population and
the customer base that we have I think
50 stores now again I'm asking for
competition for what I'd be looking for
but I'm just telling you how are you
going to collect the tax that that Jim
and mik supposed to collect
if you got 15 stores they'd have to do
two3 million2 or3 million each a month
in sales how long did it take for these
stores to open up from when the program
began it's not the stores that the
problem it's the cultivation it takes
two years to build the cultivation out
of any sizable size and quality okay so
so this anyhow to be clear so again I
think number one we're not talking about
cultivation licenses right we're talking
about retail store locations retail
operations right not and and when you
look at the geographical size of Maine
as compared to New Hampshire a
significant difference as well as to why
you may want more stores in Maine than
you want in New Hampshire because just
getting from one end of main to the
other you can't get there from here and
so I think that there's a reason why
they might have more stores for access
to the community versus New Hampshire
they got 40 in one in Port in Portland
it's just ridiculous we could do
Portland with
one okay you guys know more about it
than me I wait go to represent H and
over here San the gon I was going to say
I think the basis of having this
conversation initially was because uh
people were distressed that we were
losing money from our surrounding states
so 15 is better than zero and if and if
the whole premise is that we're losing
so much money from Vermont Massachusetts
and and Maine in these sales then then
15 should be adequate to start with the
model we haven't seen before Senator
gon in my opinion and you can correct me
if I'm wrong do you not do a
disproportionately high volume of
business at a few stores so I'm thinking
if we have one on Route three 93 uh
Route One a few other places they're
going to do a predominantly large
portion of the business so we're prudent
about our location of the 15 that's
that's absolutely true but then you guys
would have to dictate where the stores
go you you you understand that's what
we're doing but yeah
again uh liquor always has that on
license EAS on location to decide where
stores go and don't so enough all right
so as a as a consensus we had uh for a
majority of the committee we're okay
with adding language to cap the number
of store locations at 15 again this
isn't breaking new ground we do it with
uh the atc's we also do with charitable
gaming uh for um retail sports betting
locations we're allowed 10 in the state
and that's it so it's not new ground
that we're breaking where we've limited
it on Startup to see what the impact was
um so I think it's a reasonable
adjustment
um the last one was do you want to do
this one I I'll let you do it yeah
thanks um so we have some language out
of the governor's office talking about
political contributions and lenses so
I'd ask that everybody read it and we'll
take some input on it um the language
just says no recipient of a state
licensed to operate a cannabis
establishment shall Lobby or attempt to
influence legislation relative to
cultivation testing manufacturer
packaging or sale of cannabis or
cannabis products contribute funds to
any entity engaged in these activities
or participated in political activity
this prohibition shall not apply to
entities that have not had a license for
at least 18
months so again the the uh that's the
language that's being put forward I'm
open discussion I have a little concern
about Citizens United and that
conversation that speech is money is
speech and denying that might cause some
conflict here but I'm open to discussion
before we get uh the Attorney General's
office weighs in
the the franchisee purpose right you're
essentially acting as a government act
so you can restrict speech on the
government but not on a private
individual so a franchisee I think this
you they're voluntarily deciding to
become a franchisee I don't think that's
a first am issue I guess for our friends
sitting here and they're all all
together are they would they be able
this would apply to them perhaps
I guess I would ask Daryl is you name
one other place in State Statute where
we limit this for a private L LLC
because that's what these businesses are
the private llc's in in uh a franchise
arrangement with um with the state where
else in statute do we ever limit speech
by a private LLC well it's if they have
to receive the state license to operate
a candidas
establishment like taking that I
understand that you're saying that licy
gives up that right uh let's go to Sen
Whitley and then we go to Frank yeah so
I also have constitutional concerns with
this first amendment concerns and just
BEC these are private businesses that
are getting uh you know they're getting
a license they're getting a franchise
that doesn't make them government in no
way does it make that government um and
so I you know again this is very rushed
you know folks have to leave very soon
this has potential constitutional
problems I think this is very this is
not right for decision point in such a
rushed way right now
Dave I I mean circumstances does happen
when somebody gets a A Federal
Grant and they're not recipients of
federal grants a lot of times the
condition is they're not to do any
lobbying or any of those type of
activities the the the the worry here is
that we don't want the to create a big
tobacco atmosphere in New Hampshire that
is happening in other states we we don't
want it to be where a lot of money is
being thrown around we want it to we
don't want
it we don't want that to happen here
where uh the whole conversation is taken
over by people with a lot of money you
heard the gentleman say uh he owns a lot
of
stores and he's going to have a unfair
Advantage if he's able to put up all
kinds of Lobby activities where we are
trying to make this the one of the
reasons we're trying to make this a
franchise model is so we don't get a big
tobacco we don't get that big money
coming into new Hampshire in polluting
the conversation what's best for New
Hampshire further conversation Frank I
definitely see the chief's um concern in
terms of influence I do think though we
have potential First Amendment issues
with this um I definitely want to run
this by our legal team but I think that
I mean the chief's point I think is is
why I think it's so important that we on
the commission like the commission that
we're establishing that we don't have
certain people on that commission that
we limit throughout other aspects of
this legislation the power and influence
of certain entities you know so that we
have like we decided not to put the a
member of franchisee on the oversight I
think that's a great way to limit their
power ability to influence but I think
this has some potential issues Tim and
then darl just a couple questions I
mean we don't limit um the opportunity
to lobby for the gambling establishments
that have licenses or any other kind of
license I think this might possibly set
a bad
precedence so let me let me just explain
one of the rationals for this I'm just
explain the rationale so you have 15
franchises right they may not agree on
every
policy but they they're kind of
operating on I don't I don't know team's
the right word but they're operate you
don't want picture other franchises
right if they're all arguing amongst
themselves lob being for different
things part of it is is trying to keep
it keep some
cohesiveness amongst the franchises now
that's just kind of how this came about
now is it an actual First Amendment
violation uh I think if they agree to
take the state license they're doing so
in advance that's why it's you this
should not apply to the entities that
have not had license for at least 18
months it's applying to anyone who
decides to apply for a license after the
fact they do that that they know what
what goes along with that
license they're doing it voluntarily no
one's no one's making anyone do anything
right long as they know it in advance
now if we were to change do this five
years from now I don't think you can do
it I think at that point that's
problematic further
discussion so let's do it this way all
those in favor of adopting this language
into to the bill somewhere signify by
raising your
hand two three four all those
oppose it's four three with a whole
bunch of people not voting um for
understandable reasons so why don't we
do this as an addendum because it's not
a majority of the committee that's done
it so we'll do it as a talking point to
be added into the bill and the committee
report saying there was discussion about
the influence of the industry uh through
lobbying on expansion and um um and pro
prohibiting that that lobbying efforts
and we can put some sort of note in the
in the rest of the amendment to the bill
or the addendum to the bill can I can I
just add that the last sentence is
tortured language and can be drastically
improved if just when you had that in
the addendum you just put a little note
that someone really should look at that
last sentence and clean it
up all right what else do you have on
your list there I know our friends at
the atcs
had some issues with some of the
definitions of how it would be
coordinated so I was ask if they they
can come up with um someone
phhs I'll just bring it went up to speed
during the lunch break we had a very
pleasant conversation about some of the
definitions and basically
like we're trying to balance some of
these definition pieces together because
if if an ATC were to apply be a
franchise he and be granted that and
they were to then close their
storefront how would that work with the
rest of these rules and part of it is
was maybe defining what a therapeutic
product is is not and where would that
go here also uh tweaking some of the
definition and of manufacturing stuff
like that so we'll we'll take the let
you guys take the floor and explain that
thank you Mr chairman again for the
record Matt Simon representing Granite
Leaf cannabis Y and uh good afternoon
everybody uh Brandon pic with tascal
Wellness thank
you first of all thank you for listening
to our previous testimony and reading
our previous memos had some good
conversations about how to integrate uh
the therap at cannabis program with uh
the proposed franchise model um we're we
still you know I've read this a few
times today I'm still trying to make
sense of uh some of some of the
provisions
um the biggest problem was already fixed
uh early this morning
when in uh on page five line 13 and 14
the sentence reading alternative
treatment centers cannot be licensed to
duly operate at the same location is a
franchise cannabis retail outlet so that
was deleted this morning thank you for
doing that that that gives us some
clarity and
restores my understanding of overall
what my understanding is and please
correct me if I'm wrong the atcs have
agreed uh to give up the store branding
to no longer have branded
atc's uh if we do receive
franchise licenses we would operate the
franchise but we would be able to
continue selling to patients and in fact
this would expand access because any
franchise store would be able to sell
therapeutic products to patients so to
be clear we think that's a good idea and
and we we agree with that
concept go right ahead rest that
apologize I I give one second he missed
the morning hecting that language I was
late I apologize so we struck langu in
Striking that language under Roman num
16 the that's part of the idea is that
you can't have the licensed ATC and a
licensed franchisee operating at the
same
location in a retail
capacity we weren't going to so by
striking
that yeah I think we're just
misunderstanding each other Senator that
sentence wasn't in the previous draft of
the bill it was a new surprise for us
this morning that we weren't super happy
with and it promptly got deleted so
we're we're back to a place of trying to
make sense of what we do see in front of
us uh the section that goes along with
this is uh being on page 12 and
proceeding on to 13 there was a whole
section of rulemaking on how
specifically
atc's would apply for and be licensed
and it included some restrictions that
patients I think are going to think are
very important that we continue serving
patients and continue to
prioritize serving
patients um but in terms of process
there there's there's still some things
we're not clear about we thought a
definition of of therapeutic products
and um sorry just to finish ask a quick
question of you so again I want to make
sure we're clear is that the issue is
that I think at some point once you
apply to be a retail store you're no
longer acting as an ATC but the problem
is with that sentence in there even the
ATC can't apply to be a retail store
because we were you were
explicitly prohibited from becoming a
retail store that's why we struck that
language before right I understand that
uh we would still be doing all the
things we currently do to serve patients
we would still be cultivating and
producing products we would still still
be dispensing to patients we would still
be doing all the things that RSA 126x
authorizes us to do and unless we change
RSA 126x we'll still be defined as atc's
under 126x so that's something that
probably needs to be cleaned up a little
bit uh and we're we're happy to spend
time in December and go through RSA 126x
and make sure everything in there
comports with what this bill will be
doing and clean up any of that um but I
do think for the definition of franchise
cannabis retail outlet first of all we
need to make it clear currently it says
uh an entity licensed as a
franchisee uh to purchase cannabis from
Cannabis cultivation facilities purchase
cannabis and cannabis products from
Manufacturing facilities and sells
cannabis and cannabis products or
cannabis accessories or paraphernalia to
Consumers and instead of ending on
consumers if the intent is for all
franchise stores to be able to sell to
adults uh you would need to add uh
registered patients or qualifying
patients and designated caregivers so
that all retail franchise stores would
have that and Brandon has that
definition yeah I'll just be a little
more precise so recommendation is after
uh cannabis product Manufacturing
facilities include uh purchase
therapeutic cannabis products from
alternative treatment centers that would
allow any of the franchise Outlets to
purchase the products and then also at
the end to uh sell Therapeutics
therapeutic cannabis products to
qualified patients and their designated
caregivers uh we would also recommend a
definition of what a therapeutic
cannabis product is in the definition
section uh which would be a cannabis or
cannabis product that's produced by an
alternative treatment
center dosing and potency limits uh
established under this chapter shall not
apply to therapeutic cannabis products
so those definition tweaks should tie
into the intent here which is to allow
any franchise retail out to purchase and
sell therapeutic products to uh
patients
so three three things number one is to
adjust the franchise cannabis retail
outlet definition to include the
language you had to create create a
definition of what a therapeutic product
is as compared to a retail product and
then lastly the third one what was the
last one
again uh yeah basically I mean that's
correct so the the franchise retail
outlet definition would allow them to
both purchase and distribute the
therapeutic products create a definition
for therapeutic products and and then
the last minor thing the bottom of page
10 um we would recommend changing the
term therapeutic grade to therapeutic
cannabis products to match the
definition
yeah uh so that's all least I got should
change therapeutic gra products to
therapeutic
products yeah therap to canis probably
pick of title it doesn't
matter so can you okay so let's let's
talk in general right now and as the
commiss as the committee goes those
adjustments make sense in order be able
to allow the ATC to move over into the
retail Market does that sound like a
reasonable adjustment because of
definition changes we' got is there any
objection to that make sure I understand
what was having because we always said
they could be the cultivators for the
retail what I'm hearing what I'm hearing
is
that when the this product is now in the
retail
environment that the same controls we
have over the atc's Personnel in terms
of their training uh the product
labeling uh they still have to have that
same the employees of the retail have to
have that training I me I guess let me
is that what I'm hearing we already we
already put the training in for anybody
in the retail side we don't we're not
changing the therapeutic side but the
I'm what I was thought I heard was that
the requirements of the therapeutic
product right that's what we're talking
about here is the the product
itself obviously it can't exceed the
limits that are already in the
retail right the five bgrs can't exceed
that so even though therapeutic products
have very high dosages
you can't exceed it in the retail
environment so the only thing this seems
to tell me was that if the product is
provided to a retail
outlet that you are saying they the
person who is selling or the person
who's marketing it has to have sound
sounds like have to have the ATC
training that's what I heard but maybe
I'm represent our our intent with the
recommendation was to allow any of the
franchise retail stores to
sell therapeutic products which would be
higher potency and they could only be
sold to patients or caregivers so yeah
it allows you know more access points
for patients yes so that's to me a deal
breaker because I think when we sit here
and argue about how we want to have caps
to say okay but if somebody shows up
with a health car
then then now we have the same problem
fundamentally with the difference in my
mind between the
atc's and the retail is that the atc's
pay have no franchise
fee and have the sky a limit on your
dosage whereas the retail has a
franchise
fee and yes there is a limit to how much
THC the product can
have respectfully representative hunt uh
You' missed a couple of meetings there
have been a number of discussions that
took place when you were not here and
the commission I believe did reach
consensus and did agree that it would be
desirable for franchise stores to be
able to serve to sell to patients
registered patients as well as adults
and I see the chairman is nodding at a
higher
dosage so the idea and I'm just going to
backtrack little bit the idea was can't
have two masters right that that was
your correct line so we have our atc's
who are I from when I gather are
interested in in entering the retail
Market no one's making them do it but
that's what they want to
do initially they wanted to have a dual
license and two signs and all that and
and I I just want to hear what you guys
agreed to well um the idea was if
they're gonna operate a become a
franchise e person that's assuming that
they're app they could operate a
franchise right and then give up the ATC
yes but the idea is what with you still
have an ATC Market the idea was rather
than create an unfair Market Advantage
for you know some of the
franchises is that they would be able to
distrib any franchisee would have the
opportunity to sell therapeutic products
to patients but we're going to limit
manufacturing to the existing
manufacturers we're not going to have
more at a higher dosage they could sell
the higher dosage provide the person has
the therapeutic card and is the
franchise fee still in effect or not yes
yes if it's in a retail store okay so
the difference is is they would can sell
higher dosage if they have a medical
card therapeutic card and it still goes
towards the franchise for your and grow
sales okay but there if it's a if they
choose to stay as a true ATC no retail
sale then they're not subject to the the
tax the the fee any kind of franchise Fe
on that medical product
okay represent uh just wonder if there's
a stickup about the selling the higher
THC levels then would we then could we
go back and look at the medical cards
and see that maybe the doctor has agreed
that this person requires a higher THC
level so the interesting part about
m a big can s big can of problems um so
again the issue is around doctors don't
write a prescription they qualify you as
having having a certain condition and by
law we allow those people with those I
to be able to get medical what happens
is they they tell you what you're they
give you they tell you what you're
supposed to have verb it's not really
written down anymore no I understand I
there's no way to really enforce that R
so they more certify the underlying
condition that is that is legally able
to have a card what's the justification
for having higher THC levels on the
medical side then maybe it all gets
brought down in
general that's an option just the
thought all right so you guys all right
so in general
how how do you want to proceed we have
these definitions are necessary for the
atcs to be able to move from an ATC
Market to a retail Market um and run a
retail shop um are we okay with the
adoption of the general principle of
adopting those we'll give it to Daryl to
be able to change those three conditions
we talked about right um adding the Lang
adding the change in in the section
about the franchise cannabis retail
store um to clean up some language um to
deal with therapeutic um creating a
definition for the therapeutic cannabis
and then lastly I always forget what the
third one was any recommendation from
our
experts Mike do we have a definition
what therapeutic cannabis is in
in
current yes anything they sell is a
theraputic product's no there's no
differentiation of adult product
versus because there is no so aerape
would be
anyc
manufactur
ands so there's no differentiation
there's nothing in that law that would
allow us to differentiate between retail
product and therapeutic product unless
you guys have a definition that we can
use yeah so our recommendation with the
you know seven minutes we just thought
about it was to essentially
uh preclude dosing and potency
restrictions from a therapeutic product
so it's any you know it's any cannabis
product that HC produces and that the
dosing and potency limits don't don't
apply to those
products
um so what we wrote was it means a
cannabis or cannabis product produced by
an alternative treatment center dosing
and potency limits established under
this chapter shall not apply apply to
therapeutic cannabis
products I have a concern that we're
going to be creating a schizophrenic
system to where you know this booth
sells this and that Booth sells this and
if we have THC limits let's have THC
limits right so again I think the
concept was allowing the recreational
the retail stores to be able to sell
therapeutic product as developed by the
therapeutic industry um and be subject
to to what they give up is the fact that
it's subject to Taxation and you have to
have a card you can't walk in and say I
want to buy the therapeutic and not have
a card you have to have the card which
means that you've met with Mike or gone
through the process with DHHS for for
what that looks like um and and but you
also can still have for again for an ATC
that chooses not to and just wants to
stay in the not for profit World they
could just stay over there and sell just
the therapeutic product and no retail
product
whatsoever just a q said quick question
question so if somebody comes in with a
medical cut
and do they get any do you get any
direction from what their medical
provider suggested recommended or they
can just come in because they have the
medical card and say I want the highest
potency so as a matter of policy we can
sell them anything on our menus uh in
some cases a very small number of cases
the medical provider does provide notes
and does provide specific instructions
in cases where do uh we are required by
law to follow that and we do um
so that's an issue that could be
addressed in ruem that's one of the
reasons I was concerned about the
rulemaking being pulled out of this
draft uh but that can something we can
deal with in January perhaps um but yeah
we we are required to follow the
providers instructions when they do
provide instructions but the vast
majority don't have instructions so it's
the choice of the consumer with the
medical Cod that's correct thank
you further discussion and just so to
clear that's how it is under the
existing therapeutic program so yeah I
yeah the doctor's not allowed to write
it down the patient just walks in and
hopefully he's honest with the with the
ATC they have the option although it's
encouraged to have a
consultation
requ APC to follow provider instruction
correct but the doctor's not allowed to
put it in writing but he
said sometimes oh we heard different
testimony so da I mean he just not the
aru but this gentleman just said that
most of the time the doctor doesn't give
him Str so I'm it just seems kind of
ironic it just as an observation it's
supposed to be a quasi medicine not a
prescription but and but the consumer
chooses what his doses each other so
yeah that's cannabis is a unique product
the fact that there are no lethal
overdoses means that right I'll I'll
just stop saying I'll stop talking so
again so the question is do we change
this language to deal with this
transitional issue we have with atcs
being able to get into the market we
have some base definitions that we can
add we Daryl can send them around um to
everybody once he's drafted it and
brought it into the bill well
therapeutic grade cannabis products
means a cannabis product that ex which
is already
defined that exceeds the potency
limitations created by this
chapter and manufactured by a license
ATC
sure
right all
right so we're good with that those
changes what darl do you have anything
else on your list of things we got to
address
because that's was the last one on my
list
um what's
it no no you just get to eat your
gummies all right anything else um I'm
waiting for Daryl to finish typing but
is anybody anybody other than Daryl have
anything they want to bring up yep I
would just with regard to the Cannabis
advisory commission um I think it would
be very helpful to include language in
there that would prohibit people from
having um Financial incentives from
receiving some sort of a conflict of
interest kind of language that maybe
perhaps the board members have to be um
maybe they can't have investments in
marijuana they can't have certain things
there has to be some sort of disclosure
so we can trust that people are are
working in their best
interest I'm going to write that section
up and I'll give it to darl and I'll
include that there'll be no conflict of
interest um either by Financial
Financial um
matters to be a
member and anybody else if I could if
you and you may even want to consider
immediate family members in that as
well household members just ethics
language that we use for standard ethics
language anything else so remember if
you have a call out that's beyond the
bill that was an item you didn't agree
with and you want to call it out for the
policy committee to adopt then you need
to send it to Daryl by Thursday because
our reports due by Friday and the
report's going to be under Daryl
signature not the committee signature so
he'll do it as chairman saying this is
what was discussed and just so everyone
knows I am actually leaving country on
wedes on Wednesday so Wednesday night
but so if you expecting to reach me
Thursday morning it's not goingon to
work so try to get to him as soon as you
can if you have a call out for the
addendum we I think we have to as a
commission still have to make a vote on
a yay or name well no we don't have to
so it can be the report can be under
your signature as the activities of the
commission and the bill is the m
majority of the I I think it's important
some people there's a minority a
majority and a Minority Report well
that's why they're going to send you
aend dend language here's the bill we
drafted right that we had General
consensus the entire majority of the
committee and then the second piece will
be as a committee report not Bill the
addendums at or call outs like
consumption and I think we still need to
take take the actual foral vote now you
know this bill again this is not even a
bill this is just a hypothetical it's
not a final product but I think we need
to actually vote as a I I have a problem
voting on something I don't have in I've
always had in my committee my committee
it's always been that when we vote we
don't vote on what we think the
amendment is going to look like I I have
to I see the document before I would you
like me have this printed out for you
yes please but just this language was
this understanding what this last
process I make sure I understand it
correctly okay so but in terms of taking
a vote right at this moment I I feel
we're not well we're not meeting there's
no other meeting I hear you you can I'm
just telling I don't feel comfortable
voting at this moment I you know because
I I don't I don't even know what I'm
voting on so the recommendation's not
even necessarily this bill where this is
a proposal right but here will this
franchise model work as discussed and
this is kind of a basis for it is every
provision we call that a straw vote I
guess so so again the the Daryl can Smit
it out we just do a you can do just an
approval by email I think there was some
concern about doing an actual vote for
putting like the AG on record for
federal law you know and that probably
not a good vote to take right and so I
always vote again there were some people
there were some things that we again we
were going to look at this as a
Chairman's report of the commission that
works for me too right and then it BS up
Daryl signature we don't have to vote on
it it's here's a list of everything that
we talked about here's the things we all
agreed on I got that I was fine with you
it's it was his insistent and and then
and then secondarily to that is that
anybody who has like I still have
concerns about public consumption I'm
going to give it to Daryl as a a dentum
item saying that in this section the
committee couldn't reach consensus and
this is my feeling as a majority you
know of that I want enhanced secondary
penalties right and and allow for that
um so I'll add that as a outside the
bill conversation well I guess that to
to bring It full circle part of the
charge was to create legislation for
next year so the question is um we're
not necessarily voting on that uh
because we don't know who's going to
bring that bill in so we'll have a we'll
have a a bill without actual being a
bill but it's just a language of if a
bill was to go forward this is what we
think the bill should look like yeah and
except for these Provisions where we
like we couldn't come to a full
consensus so there are people at the
enement provision for the ACLU right
they may want to create a little call
out that says that we think that the
enement should be in and this is what we
think it should look like okay but it's
outside the bill because as a committee
we voted not to include that language
right and that gives the policy
committee some direction whoever gets it
to say here's the bill starting point
and here's some things that are still
left open to discuss okay and that'll be
the Chairman's
report
Mr chair when do you want our Minority
Report to be given to you well in order
to have a Minority Report I we need to
have a vote you have to actually a vote
on this so I think what I what i' like
to do is I probably can have this pass
around and print it out and everyone
wants to read it them me just you don't
have our business and if you have call
outs just send them the call outs again
they'll do an addendum to the committee
so but technically commission you don't
have to have that vote here you can you
draw up the document and it's like
whether we sign off off on it or not
okay and so you create the document you
put everything in it you send it out and
maybe even uh you know Jared and ran
they might they can still have an
opportunity to sign it if they agree
with what is the finished product so
that that that in terms of not having
necessarily a vote in this room having a
vote recorded vote it is that whether
people want to sign off on can that be
do you mind checking to see if that
could be done by
email you it's it's sort of like when we
when we do committee conference if you
don't sign up it's dead right you can
also report in you can also say go sign
off for me to somebody exactly alandro
you you have the most experience of all
the elected folks
here as I understand the committee Mak
report committee report what
happened the Corpus of the report is
what took place here right at the
conclusion rep that's it that's your
report to the committee that's it's
under chairman signature so as this just
what we said this is what happened right
okay works for
me all right
without I'm supposed to make a
recommendation is that the charge of the
commission the bill the report will be
the bill and and the addendum where's
the charge pull up the legislation
what's the is the
charge so establish a
commission it's to establish a
commission to study the purpose of
proposing legislation State controlled
sales of
cannabis so the commission met we have a
document we went through 37 pages with
various edits and cleanups um and that's
the core piece of or as Corpus as as
Senate delandra said that's the Corpus
of the bill and then any Committee
Member can submit a note to it be
attached to the report the bill for
areas they disagree with or agree with
well I'll just ask again when do you
want us to have our Minority Report that
we've already prepared given to
you but is there going to be more than
one Minority Report now no no we work
together as a team minority
is it's just an addendum is addendum no
no no we we agreed that we talked about
and discussed as a committee you might
have been on vacation again that you
would be allowed to do a Minority
Report so again the public consumption
component anybody can put in ad dendam
in and says that this bill the bill is
submitted
people can send their Denman uh call us
but there's no voting by email right
so it needs to that needs to be done and
if we if we don't we don't do what we're
supposed to do we can't make a
recommendation on proposed legislation
either way so I can have it printed out
for him to look
at right so that's the charge of the
commission we we have to do it so how
many people were actually voting it
seems like not one two
three so the last vote was seven
people the seven people still here well
no the last vote there were a lot of
people that didn't vote that I didn't
force to vote like nope those three
didn't vote at all no exactly so but
they're they're voting members the last
vote we just had was four to three right
because only seven people chose to voice
all those seven people still in the room
yeah
so okay let's go vote again would you
like me to pass no it's fine let's just
vote we
got be recognized to make a
motion um I moved ought to pass uh on
this uh um this proposal but I think you
want to move you do you recommend the
proposal I recommend that this is the
language that is used for legislation
for next
session is there a
second
than this exective by
frag is there any
discussion after all that we're good
again I think Mr chairman the question
is going to be are you going to allow an
addendum for this report like I may vote
for the bill I may vote for this to move
forward but I want an addendum on
certain topics that I didn't have
agreement with the committee on 100% and
listen to my to my friends on here that
are elected
members I'm not asking whether you
support this in in a house vote or a
senate vote but this the provisions in
here part of a compromise that's that's
what I'm kind of getting we're not
recommending this ought to pass per se
you know on on the floor of leg body
putting this forward is Provisions that
no none of us agree on every so so again
the vote is on the 37 Pages we just went
through in detail right and all the
little minor changes we made in the last
in in the last few hours and then there
three other Provisions we've added that
we we have and that's the the Cannabis
advisory commission the limitation on
state stores and the addition of the
Distributing distribution and
warehousing language that we missed in
the bill um so that's what we're voting
on whether you agree with that concept
of that of that as the bill going
forward and then every one of us will
have the chance to write Daryl um either
a summary letter or individual articles
on what we we disagree with in the bill
so that the policy committee can take it
up everybody clear on that that's what
the vote's about all
right all those in favor of the bill as
we amended today um again not saying
that you support legalization but you
support the bill as we presented it
raise your
hand all those
opposed one two three four five
six
I want you to do as a Chairman's report
is there another
motion those it's been moved that it
filed as a Chairman's report not as a
commission's report we'll just outline
exactly everything we've done here um
under Daryl signature rather than as a
committee vote so first of all um I I'm
I'm not recognizing the charge of the
commission is to make a recommendation
not a summarize a summary of what we did
here in either way way the total vote of
this commission it's not binding on the
legislative either way I understand
being on record one way or another I
know some of not everyone can vote some
people have an interest in this one way
or another but the idea
is you know we just we're going to put
out what what the committee recommended
what they didn't what they didn't
recommend that's it so you in all
fairness you guys might have gotten the
vote you were looking for if everyone
showed up to do the job that they were
CH that happens a lot that happens a lot
the I hear but the vote didn't go your
way and and it's what it is so right now
the recommendation the motion that's on
the floor is to make this a Chairman's
report which would include the language
that we adopted as the report saying
this is what we got consensus on um and
and approved with a majority vote of and
then I'm not I'm not recognizing someone
for that motion because that that motion
is inconsistent with what the charge of
the commission is can I clarification if
we are if we adopt the motion that was
just made does that negate the vote that
was just had if we adopt yes if you had
if you adopted that motion it would just
be a Chairman's report not a
recommendation of the majority of the
committee and the Chairman's reporting
out this but he doesn't want but darl's
taking his chairmanship back and saying
he's not recognizing the motion so it's
not the charge of the commission is very
clear is to make a recommendation but
the but the recommendation was not to
adopt so that's the vote that last taken
and that's what the
commissions right Y and they can be
they'll be a Minority
Report yeah so be making a majority
report ENT essentially but I don't I
don't think it's
gonna
so the vote just I just want to know
what I was voting for I abstained last
time I just want to know what I'm voting
for here is that we're voting that this
report was done but
we
if there's things in there we disagree
with we're
not so not every the draft that we put
together it's 37 Pages no one in this
room agrees with everything in that
draft even if you support Canabis on any
level okay what we're trying to that I'm
just saying that the now that we've
concluded basically our work we make a
few tweaks that Senator Lang discussed
the charge of the commission is to make
a recommendation not just a summary of
what we talked what went on here so when
by making the recommendation that this
is the legislation be proposed does not
mean that you support that legislation
it just means that's what we're
essentially if legislation is to be
filed that's consistent with that
language and obviously not not that you
agree with all of it but the the concept
of it okay and you can make your own
objections addendums to say well I I
although I supported recommendation of
legislation I didn't support these
sections right and some of those are
policy sections that are outside the
charge of the Commission in the first
place otherwise we could anything on
possession limits anything on driving uh
some of the the health aspects all that
stuff is really outside the scope of
this just putting together the franchise
model is really a smaller section of the
bill so some of those those those policy
and social issues that we've been
discussing the annulments all that part
is really outside of what we need to be
doing here so I think it's important to
do it all at once and we have those
conversations but all we're doing is
saying this is what we came up with this
is what we're putting forward if we
agree with that or not if that's not
what we agree with if someone has
another version they want to present so
be it or they can be a Minority Report
but we're not saying that anyone
supports this policy on by any means
simply because they support passively
problem is Mr chair we've taken a vote
and um based on the the thing and the
vote was not to make a recommendation on
on not to support the bill and the
recommendation in the bill so at this
point the Minority Report which would be
the people who want to support this bill
would write a thing but the majority
report would be after meeting the
committee recommends no bill go forward
because that's what the recommendation
was I still think that motion needs to
be made yeah I'm about to make I'm about
to make that motion I I'd like to make a
motion Mr chair and unless anyone wants
a reconsideration because they were
confused
I I recommend we adjourn and come back
in two
days we can't one December is the date
yeah it's not going to work two
days so you want to come on the 29th
come yeah maybe get some people to show
up point of order I was gonna make a
motion
get all right well listen no so you
weren I'm asking I don't even think we
canet meet the notice requirement two
days it be three
of so unless someone wants to make make
a
reconsideration so representative K Hill
you recognized no um is if someone was
on the prevailing side would have to
make a motion for reconsideration
stained the only it's only the five that
would be S Ganon the four over here and
one other person I can't who on the
commission anyone make actually
reconsideration arguments always been
you have to be on the prevailing side
before we add does anyone wish to would
anyone make a
reconsideration
anyone I do a I do a motion to
reconsider based on your explanation
about what this report means he was
again I re I'm pretty sure you abstain
from the vote no that doesn't apply in
committees and commissions from what I
understand
that does apply on the
law so if I could just to be
clear this doesn't mean that somebody
can't pick up this language and run with
it in the house or Senate this doesn't
change anything exactly I know that
that's why even negative recommendation
I wouldn't say corre oh no like this is
corre trust me someone's in a end the
world at the any time a Chairman's
report is not with the charge of the
Commissioners right so I I don't see how
doing that is right this doesn't prevent
any any language going forward so all
I'm asking
is so the point of order is whether
someone can make a reconsideration if
they didn't vote in the first
place
believe motion before we we made that
point of
order
was that motion seconded before we
didn't I wasn't allowed to make my
motion yeah all right well so let me ask
you this is there is there a motion for
reconsideration that it's willing to be
made and will it even matter trust me if
the other everyone else still um decides
not to vote or whatever it's it's not
going to change the
outcome so we can do a reconsideration
that is helpful Mr chair the only thing
I will say we do have time if we want to
meet on Wednesday so we can have a
finalized copy of the bill in our hands
to vote um so everybody understands the
components because I know there was some
that were concerned about that um
otherwise I think right now um we've
we've rejected the bill at this point
does that satisfy the notice reir yes so
commission need only 24 24 hours so we
can meet on the
29th and we could have a finalized
version of the bill and have discussion
but understand that as it stands now the
last motion to pass on this committee
was to reject the bill and the majority
report would be to reject the bill and
the Minority Report would be to accept
the bill we could still do it if we Boo
or we can hold this off and see if after
language comes out everybody we can
consider do a reconsideration vote um
for the members as long as we're allowed
to meet in that time here I guess I mean
you can just ignore what I'm going to
say but I would I object to that I
object to the fact that this is cheesy
maneuvering
had the vote and and this will carry
this will not prevent anyone from going
forward and making legislation and
picking up this paper and copying it
word for word and including any one of
you on there as a bill sponsor or
co-sponsor and that's I agree with you
100% that's why I think the I think the
commission the recommendation although
it's it may hold some way It ultimately
can still be anything can be I agree so
let me again I'm just going to ask one
really crazy question it's going to get
me people mad at me but Chief were you
the appointed member by the by the New
Hampshire Chief Association or was it
somebody else I'm the substitute because
he's out of state he's out of country
right so we already counted his vot
there's a point whether it's a legal
vote because he's not the appointed
author it wouldn't it wouldn't have
mattered because then would have been 44
he would have needed to raise that point
of order so during before the vote not
now you guys I have a lot of respect for
all are you really going to tell me
let's start with uh let's start with Tim
and then we'll come over
toor let Senator alandro speak Tim he
hasn't spoken as long as you're not
gonna make a
motion Senor aland he hasn't spoken on
this I I respect sen Senator delandro he
follows the the rules and order thank
you very much for defer I I I I suggest
that the report from this committee be
without recommendation the document be
presented but there is there isn't a
recommendation we we we did what we we
did what we were supposed to do we heard
everything we came up with a document
the document is presented but without
recommendation so is that as
chairman is that something that can be
is that a motion that can be made well
first so L was on The Winning Side so if
he makes a motion to reconsider we can
vote to reconsider and then we can make
a different motion to do it without
recommendation that would allow it to go
forward with the language of the bill
that is in with all due respect Senator
delandro yes I was recognized I asked to
make a motion
okay you you know so he was going to go
second so go ahead we have an obligation
to follow the rules even if we don't
like the rules or don't like the outcome
we've all lost on days we didn't want to
lose I made a mo I I asked to be
recognized we can go back and play the
tape in order to make a motion I'm going
to make a motion make a motion I'd like
to make a motion that we recommend as a
committee that no legislation go
forward motion
second made second it's been moved and
seconded the recommendation of the
committee report would be to not go
forward with any legislation although I
think actually you said that literally I
don't know that you can actually I'm not
sure it's a valid you can't prohibit a
representative or senat to bring
legalization language for you can
recommend that they not do it but it's
not binding on anybody any
legis so which so there's a motion and
there's a second to I think was the
point that senat alandre was trying to
make that i' making no recommendation
May somewhat satisfy some of
the make sure you qualif what is your
motion rephrase the motion re restate
just motion stop anybody from putting in
so what is your motion on just if I
could Mr chairman just a point for
discussion what what I'm recommending is
we have done the work that was that was
presented to us we have come up with no
recommendation that's what the report
that's the report should indicate we did
take a vote and there was a clear
majority saying we don't want to put
this forward so they don't there's no
recommendation this is not
recommend I I'm making a motion that we
don't put that forward
this committee report is that you just
want to say you you want to make a
motion that the recommendation is that
no report is moved forward correct
okay that's the recommendation motion
second okay and now second motion is
that no report recommendation move
forward no he can't say no legislation
he can only say no report because he he
can't bind anybody for put a
bill well it's not binding either
way I get it you guys don't like the
fact no it's a recommendation like
that's what we took a vote the vote
didn't go the way a lot of you guys
would like representative respectfully
all we're saying is the recommendation
was the first motion was to propose
legislation it didn't go forward now the
recommendation is to not put forward
legislation it's but you we're saying
you it's your recommendation that's
we're just rephrasing what you're saying
okay we're not taking away from the
point you're trying to make
okay that so to clarify is that is is
your um is your Rec is your uh point of
order
rescinded yes it just I think the idea
is there's going to be a majority report
that's going to recommend no legislation
on this issue be filed and there'll be a
minority that that's what that's what it
can be done that's where we are right
now know I think there are people that
are good with that I think the reason
we're getting into the weed is because
there's people who are not good with
that I think it was just a matter of how
it was pheed
okay Mr chair but in Ence we're
fulfilling the responsibility of the
committee by bringing forward a report
yes the report has found there is no
recommendation
yeah I think that's you're fulfilling
the obligation of the committee you're
stating the work of the committee and
you're stating that there is no
recommendation you okay with that motion
yes a second that's all right that's
your motion all so again all those in
favor of recommending no recommendation
and filing report signify by raising
your
hand three four five six seven eight two
and all those
oppos one two
two so on a seven to two vote the
recommendation is there's no
recommendation and we'll just present a
report of everything we've done and
people can take it for whatever it's
worth going
for is that good anything else come
before the
commission we're
done you pick which ones you
want it wouldn't matter but I think I
misunderstood the
L